Die Ligatour Europa ist zurück. Wir blicken heute nach Spanien, England, Italien und Frankreich und das tun wir mit Chris McCarthy, Fabian Pakulat, Christian Bernhardt und Jakob Haffke. Und jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich habe die Ligatur-Runde hier. Die kennt ihr wohl hoffentlich schon und wenn nicht, dann werfe ich euch das langsam vor, denn die muss man kennen. Also schön, Jungs, dass ihr alle da seid. Schönen guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen.
Gute Zeit, stark. Wir haben wieder ganz viele Themen, die ihr mitgebracht habt und trotzdem zwinge ich euch dazu, dass wir ganz kurz auf die Champions League blicken, denn so ein paar Themen drängen sich da geradezu auf. Und ich glaube, das Größte ist eigentlich Chris Liverpool 1 zu 4 gegen PSV. Wir haben schon ganz viel über Liverpool gesprochen. Wir müssen da jetzt wirklich nicht ins Detail gehen. Aber was ist denn so dein Gefühl? Wird das jetzt wirklich eng für Anis Slot?
Ja, also alleine, dass wir darüber sprechen, dass es eng werden könnte, zeigt, wie groß die Krise ist, wenn man als amtierender Meister über seinen Trainer sprechen muss und so eine Krise hat. Man hat jetzt neun der letzten zwölf Spiele verloren. Das ist zuletzt, ich habe es gerade nochmal nachgeschaut, ich habe 1953 passiert. Drei Spiele hintereinander mit drei Toren Abstand verloren. Also das ist nicht nur eine Ergebnis-Krise, das ist eine handfeste Krise im gesamten Verein.
Okay, also glaubst du, dass könnte jetzt dann, also dass wir vielleicht in ein paar Wochen sprechen und ihr sagen, jetzt war es das für ihn?
Ja, also ich glaube ja, weil in den, als wir in den letzten Folgen über Liverpool und Slot gesprochen haben, haben wir schon ein bisschen, darauf eingegangen, dass ihm auch manchmal so etwas die Antworten fehlen, dass er fast schon zu ehrlich mit dem Problem Liverpools umgeht, dass man überrascht war, wie Mannschaften gegen sie auftreten, dass man keine Antworten findet auf die langen Bälle. Und jetzt in den letzten Wochen kamen auch wirklich noch Mentalitätsproblemen dazu, auch wenn es jetzt wirklich sehr stammtisch mäßig sich anhört. Aber wenn man so auf die Spieler schaut, da sind hängende Köpfe, hängende Schultern. Die Intensität, die man mit Liverpool in Verbindung bringt, fehlt. Die Zweikampfstärke fehlt. Und ja, also das sind alles Zeichen einer dysfunktionalen Mannschaft. Und es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es sehr, sehr eng wird mit Slot. Weil so ein Lauf, wie jetzt gerade, um gerade diese letzten drei Spiele mit 0 zu Hause gegen PSV Eindhoven 1 zu 4 war es, glaube ich, und 0-3 gegen Nottingen mit Tabellenvorletzter, das ist einfach nicht tragbar. Und wenn jetzt in Schleunigs etwas passiert, dürfte es sehr, sehr eng werden.
Und das Ganze aber auch in einem Jahr, in dem die einen ihrer Mitspieler verloren haben. Diogo Schotter, wir erinnern uns dran. Also es ist eine wirklich komplexe Gemengelage. Aber wir waren ja schon tiefer drin. Ich wollte nur kurz die Nachfrage dazu stellen. Dann aber, dass die anderen auch die Möglichkeit haben, wenn sie denn wollen. Gibt es bei euch noch, wenn ihr auf eure Teams blickt und auf den gestrigen Champions-League-Spieltag, Böhne, Winne, Marks, kannst du anfangen? Gibt es irgendwas, was du bemerkenswert fandest?
Also extrem wichtig, dass Juve im Norden Norwings gewonnen hat. Die hatten ja glaube ich erst drei Punkte. Also da ging es wirklich darum, die haben den Dreier gebraucht, um einfach im Rennen zu bleiben. Und wie der dann zu Ständer kam mit diesem Tor in der Nachspielzeit und diesem Willenspiel, also das war extrem wichtig, da zu gewinnen. Ja, und vielleicht noch kurz Atalanta halt. Also Atalanta hatten wir schon beim letzten Mal. Die hatten ja da in Marseille gewonnen, wo jetzt glaube ich auch nicht unbedingt jeder gewinnt. Und dann fahren sie nach Frankfurt, obwohl sie jetzt vor kurzem Trainer gewechselt haben. Gewinnen da 3-0, haben glaube ich auch noch drei Pfostenschüsse. Also dies scheinen im Champions League-Modus zu sein. Haben jetzt zehn Punkte auch, stehen da wirklich richtig gut da. Also das europäische Atalanta, die letzten Jahre, Gasperini hat ja das Atalanta so eine europäische Mannschaft gemacht. Ja, die scheint sich auch in der Champions League, trotz einiger ein bisschen vielleicht noch Unsicherheiten, sehr wohl zu viel.
Ja, das war ein bisschen verfrüht. Als gestern habe ich noch vormittags irgendwelche Posts gesehen mit der Stärke der Bundesliga, nachdem Dortmund und Leverkusen gewonnen haben, da dachte ich mir noch so, ich würde lieber bis zum Ende des Spieltags warten. Zack, zwei Niederlagen Bayern und Eintracht Frankfurt. So schnell kann es gehen, aber auch nur im Fußball. Jakob, bei Marseille gewinnt nicht jeder, auch nicht Newcastle. Die haben verloren. Wie lief es für die französischen Clubs so?
Ja, für Marseille ein sehr wichtiger Sieg. Da können wir gleich gerne auch noch mal ein bisschen detaillierter drüber sprechen. Ansonsten Monaco läuft es ja gerade sowieso nicht so toll. Und auch da so ein Unentschieden bei Pafos, das ist jetzt glaube ich auch nicht unbedingt das, was man bräuchte, wenn man weiterkommen will. Und PSG hat gestern das gemacht, was sie diese Saison immer machen in der Champions League. Also Spektakel veranstaltet, wie Tiniya mit einem Hetrick. Und ansonsten hat man sie nochmal gezeigt, dass gerade das Mittelfeld einfach unfassbar stark ist. Und natürlich auch bemerkenswert, dass in dem Spiel alle acht Tore mit Beteiligung von PSG-Spielern gefallen sind, weil er bei Tottenham Kolomyani auch zwei Tore gemacht hat und eins vorgelegt hat, der ja von PSG ausgeliehen ist.
Solche Geschichten, naja, wisst ihr schon, ja, stimmt. Also PSG steht sehr gut da. Fabian, du bist bekannt dafür, bei jedem Thema den FC Malaga Bezug zu finden. Da bin ich jetzt total gespannt, ob du das auch hinbekommst. Champions League-Glück auf diesem Champions-League-Spieltag. Ich meine, Real 4 zu 3 bei Pireos, alle Tore von MAP, der sowieso eine unfassbare Quote inzwischen hat, bei Madrid. Und Barca 0-3 bei Chelsea verloren.
Genau. Also, wir kommen ja nachher noch drauf zu sprechen. La Liga geht es nicht so gut, den Teams geht es nicht so gut. Das merkt man schon auch in den Ergebnissen auf Europas Bühne. Und Real Madrid struggled im Moment auch so ein bisschen durch die Liga und hat eine absolute MAP-Abhängigkeit, wie wir gestern vielleicht festgestellt haben. Wenn da seine Tore nicht da sind, dann hat Real im Moment Probleme, Spiele zu gewinnen. Und das auch in Pireos, was mit Sicherheit keine leichte Bühne ist, aber schon eine machbare Bühne, sage ich jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig. Und ja, in Spanien läuft es nicht so rosig allgemein, würde ich sagen. Und wie gesagt, das spiegelt sich auch so ein bisschen auf Europas Bühne wieder.
Wobei man da jetzt natürlich auch nicht vergessen darf, Atletico gewinnt noch Last Minute gegen Inter und Athletic Bilbao.
Null-Null in Prag ist nicht so prickelnd, weil Bilbao struggelt auch ein bisschen auf Tissot. Und gestern Atletico gegen Inter, das war ja Simeone gegen seinen Herzensklub aus Italien, das musste er gestern gewinnen. Also Atletico ist schon relativ stabil, okay. Außerdem war das gestern, wie gesagt, eine Prestigessache für Diego Simeone und da haben sie sich besonders reingehängt, habe ich so das Gefühl gehabt.
Aber gut, wenn das immer klappen würde, dass immer, wenn es eine Prestigessache für den Trainer ist, das Team das Last Minute gewinnt, dann hätte der BVB eine noch bessere Bilanz. Aber das ist jetzt noch mal was anderes. Was hältst du denn davon, Fabian? Wollen wir vielleicht dann in eines deiner Themen tatsächlich reingehen? Denn du hast ja tatsächlich als eins deiner Themen mitgebracht, eben genau diesen größeren Blick auf die spanische Liga. Und du sagst, die Linie, die Tendenz, der Trend zeigt gerade nach unten bei der spanischen Liga.
Das ist leider so. Ja, wir haben, glaube ich, vor allen Dingen ist die sportliche Talfahrt auch finanziell zu erklären. Wir haben in Spanien viele Vereine haben große Probleme, nach wie vor mitzuhalten im europäischen Top-Bereich. Ja, das hat natürlich verschiedene Gründe. Unter anderem würde ich sagen, bislang die Ausnahmeklubs, Real und Barca, die mehr oder weniger machen können, was sie wollen, stehen alle anderen Vereine unter strenger Beobachtung, was die Ausgaben anbelangt. Und wir haben in La Liga ein großes Problem, was Umsätze anbelangt. Okay, La Liga verkauft sich ins Ausland ganz gut, was TV-Rechte anbelangt. Innerhalb des Landes ist es ziemlich mau, denn die Kosten sind sehr hoch, egal, ob es jetzt Ticketpreise sind, ob es Fußball-Abo sind. Und man darf nicht vergessen, die Spanier sind nach wie vor, was das Durchschnittseinkommen anbelangt, nicht irgendwie gesegnet. Ja, da ist einfach ein Durchschnittseinkommen vielleicht von einem Mitte-40-Jährigen, liegt vielleicht bei 2000 Euro, wenn überhaupt. Und wenn du dann für jedes Ticket dir zwischen 70 und 80 Euro, 70 und 100 Euro kaufen musst, obwohl du nur in Anführungszeichen wie Real gegen Osasuna ansiehst, dann ist das tough. Und dementsprechend sind die Stadien auch– muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen– so halbleer eigentlich in jedem Spieltag. Man hat immer den Vorteil, die Dauerkartenpreise sind günstig. Das heißt, die Hälfte des Stadions ist eigentlich immer voll, weil das können sich die Leute leisten. Aber was dann on top kommt, bleibt meistens leer. Man kann es noch ein paar Prozent wegrechnen, die dann vielleicht am Spieltag rein können. Und das war es dann schon, weil Auswärtsreisen gibt es eigentlich nicht. Dazu hat der Spanier auch nicht die finanzielle Kapazität. Wenn du überlegst, du musst jetzt irgendwo hinfliegen oder von mir aus auch mit dem Bus hinfahren und dann zahlt die ganze Crew nochmal, was weiß ich, 50, 60, 70 Euro Einflitzkarten, dann ist so ein Wochenende schnell mal bei 300, 400 Euro. Und das bei einem Budget von 2000 Euro im Monat, ich muss euch das nicht vorrechnen. Das ist eine schwierige Geschichte. Es ist eine sehr schwierige Geschichte. Und dann haben wir natürlich gleichzeitig auch noch das Problem, dass wir, glaube ich, fast jedes Spiel zu der anderen Uhrzeit haben. Das ist zwar toll für die TV-Rechtevermarktung, aber nicht für die Fans. Wer geht denn gerne Montagabend um 21 Uhr ins Stadion? Okay, im Sommer sage ich noch, das passt. Aber jetzt im November wird es auch hier kalt. Und dann gehst du mit deinen Kids einfach nicht im Stadion, an Montagabend. Und dann ist es auch normal, dass das Stadion nicht nur halblei ist, sondern vielleicht noch leerer ist. Okay, dann haben es zwar ein paar Chinesen gesehen, oder was weiß ich, wo in der Welt. Aber ist das wirklich refinanzierbar? Ist das wirklich ein gesundes System? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe eher das Gefühl, dass es eben nicht der Fall ist. Der spanische Verband und La Liga liegen sich sowieso ständig im Klinsch. Die können sich auf gar nichts einigen. Dementsprechend ist auch da die Zusammenarbeit sehr, sehr, sehr schlecht. Und so zieht sich ja immer die Spirale immer weiter, immer weiter und ja, so ist das eben. Und es gab jetzt noch vor, ich glaube schon 5 Jahre jetzt wieder her, einen Kredit, CVC hieß der, den alle Vereine bekommen haben, wurde von der Liga herangetragen an die Vereine, hat der Großteil auch angenommen. Da hat jeder einen guten Batzen Geld bekommen. Vorlage war, glaube ich, dass 80 Prozent in die Infrastruktur investiert werden und der Rest kann dann irgendwie ins Gehaltsbudget oder wie auch immer, oder in den Transfers fließen. Ich glaube, das war sogar noch höher. Aber das war in dem Moment für die Vereine gut, weil sie hatten auf einmal BAM Geld. Ich kann euch nur das Beispiel vom FC Malaga geben. Der hatte aufgrund seiner historischen letzten zehn Jahre, glaube ich, 40 Millionen Euro bekommen, auf den Tisch gelegt. Davon mussten dann halt, wie gesagt, 30 oder so in die Infrastruktur rein. Was gut war für den FC Malaga, der hat sich jetzt eine Sportstadt endlich bauen können, was natürlich top ist und was auch für die Zukunft natürlich gut ist, weil du dort gute Jugendspieler ausbilden kannst und nicht mehr jeder Jugendspieler gleich zu einem besseren Verein geht, weil die bessere Anlagen haben und so weiter. Aber nach diesem Patzen, den du bekommen hast, hast du natürlich auch Verbindlichkeiten bekommen, und zwar nicht ohne. Und die musst du jetzt jedes Jahr und jeden Monat abtragen. Und das tut den Verein weh, weil, wie gesagt, du hast nicht die großen Einnahmen, wo du sagst, okay, die, die, die, weiß ich nicht, wie viel, 100.000 oder was man zurückzahlen muss, muss man endlich, die stecke ich locker weg. Also es ist ein kleines Eigentor vielleicht gewesen, zumindest für die kleineren Clubs nach den Top 3, würde ich sagen. Und wie gesagt, wenn man sich halt dann so ein Vier Real anschaut oder auch ein Betty Sevilla oder wie sie auch alle heißen, die dann nach den Top 3 kommen. So, was mussten sie am Ende der Saison letztes Jahr machen? Ihre besten Spieler verkaufen, um Kohle reinzuholen. Die gehen dann meistens in die Premier League oder auch in die Bundesliga oder von mir aus auch weiss ich wohin, aber da, wo es halt ein bisschen mehr Geld gibt. Und dann hast du Qualitätsverlust. Und dann hat man natürlich gleichzeitig auch noch festgestellt, dass die spanischen Clubs dann auch vom Durchschnittsalter her natürlich ein bisschen älter geworden sind, weil man sich dann eher an ältere Spieler halten musste, die man noch finanzieren konnte, die die Qualität haben. Junge Spieler kommen nach wie vor nach in Spanien. Das ist hier– also da muss man sich keine Sorgen machen. Aber klar, die guten Jungen, die gehen halt dann ins Ausland. Das ist so ein bisschen die Gemengelage, die es so allgemein gibt. Die Fans sind genervt. Die Fans sind genervt von schlechten Schiedsrichterleistungen, von miserablen Anstoßzeiten, von überteuerten Ticketpreisen, von arschteuren Fernsehabos. Und die Clubs untereinander werden sich auch nicht grünen. Liga und Verband streitet sich. Not the best situation, I would say.
Ja, das ist ganz interessant, weil es ist jetzt natürlich so ein Metathema, über das man auch endlos diskutieren könnte. Und wir sehen es, glaube ich, immer an so Spitzen. Also wenn die Liga drüber nachdenkt, ein Spiel im Ausland stattfinden zu lassen, wozu es jetzt ja nicht kommt, aber ja nur, weil es dann so kurzfristig abgesagt werden musste, dann ist sowas auch ein Auswuchs dessen, dass man eben auf der Suche nach Geld überall ist. Und der Deal, den du ansprichst, ich hoffe, dass da alle ganz genau zugehört haben, denn CWC, das ist genau der Investor, der bei der DFL hätte einsteigen sollen. Und bei La Liga war es eben so, es haben wir alles im Tribüngespräch dazu aufgearbeitet, also hört da gerne nochmal rein, wenn es euch interessiert. In La Liga war es so, dass sie 2021 für knapp 2 Milliarden Euro eine Beteiligung gekauft haben an La Liga. Die Hälfte des Geldes wurde dann eben damals ausgezahlt und dann ebenso, wie du es gesagt hast, 70 Prozent musste in Infrastruktur, 15 Prozent durfte man für Schuldentilgung verwenden, also jeder Club für sich. Es gab allerdings da auch schon ein paar Clubs, die die Liga verklagt haben, weil sie gesagt haben, das ist ein Ausverkauf. Und das, was du jetzt nämlich dann genannt hast mit den Verbindlichkeiten, das ist quasi die Erlösbeteiligung, die CWC dafür bekommen hat. Und jetzt überlegt man sich, was haben die denn für diese zwei Milliarden Euro, die sie damals gezahlt haben, 2021 bekommen? Sie haben eine Erlösbeteiligung von 8,2 Prozent an den Erlösen der Liga für 50 Jahre bekommen. Und das ist nämlich das, was jetzt dann den Clubs fehlt. Das heißt, von dem Gewinn, den sie bekommen, gehen 8,2 Prozent an CWC. Deswegen ist das nämlich für den Investor komischerweise auch ein sehr guter Deal, weil so Hedgefonds sind auch nicht so dafür bekannt. Schlechte, die es für sich abzuschließen. Und das ist jetzt schon interessant, dass wir das jetzt hier schon merken. Und ja, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, was ich sonst noch so dazu sagen soll. Ich habe das Gefühl, die Themen sind ehrlich gesagt in allen Ländern gleich. Also ich glaube, wenn ich jetzt Chris, Jakob und Christian fragen würde, ob die Fans genervt sind von vielen Abos und von hohen Ticket, dann vermute ich mal, ja. Es scheint mir so ein übergreifendes Thema einfach zu sein, wie der Fußball sich entwickelt. Aber ich frage mich halt, Fabian, ob sich das auch bemerkbar machen wird in der Struktur der Liga. Weil wir hatten es ja schon immer so, dass der Real und Barca und vielleicht noch Athletico vorneweg marschiert sind. Und wir hatten jetzt aber auch schon immer relativ konstant so Nachwuchsfluss an Spielern, die gekommen sind, die dann auch interessant waren, die auch für kurzfristige Transfer-Erlöse gesorgt haben. Also kann man nicht vielleicht auch sagen, es ist eigentlich alles wie immer nur, man redet vielleicht auch offener drüber als noch vor ein paar Jahren, weil man auch ein paar mehr Zahlen kennt durch eben das Financial Fair Play?
Vielleicht, aber ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass das die Qualität abgenommen hat, dass auch nicht mehr die Top-Spieler hier alle herkommen. Also klar, zu Barca, zu Real kommen sie schon. Und vielleicht noch der ein oder andere zu Athletico, aber zu Real wechselt keiner mehr. Ich habe mich erinnert, da hat mal Robert Pires gespielt oder so. So etwas kann man sich heute nicht mehr vorstellen. Oder keine Ahnung, also bei Valencia war mal ein Top-Club, da haben auch geile Spieler gespielt. Champions League-Finale 2001 gegen Bayern und so weiter. So diese krassen Spieler, bis auf die Top-3, die wird es bei den kleineren Vereinen nicht mehr geben. Die werden sich weiter refinanzieren durch gute Jugendarbeit, was ja nach wie vor ein spanischer Top ist. Und es wird auch immer wieder mal Ausreißer geben. Die es vielleicht schaffen, die drei da oben ein bisschen zu kitzeln. Aber ich glaube, der Qualitätsverlust nach unten wird größer.
Jakob? Zumindest zu den Abozahlen oder den vielen Abos, die man haben muss, gibt es ja in Frankreich eine ganz interessante Entwicklung seit dieser Saison. Da es ja da den eigenen Streaming-Dienst sozusagen gibt. Also das, was ja glaube ich in jedem Land zumindest mal diskutiert wird. Und in Frankreich wird das ja jetzt, dadurch, dass man ja gerade auch schon vor der letzten Saison Riesenprobleme hatte, überhaupt jemanden zu finden, der die Liga zeigen will. Und dann haben sie ja gesagt, okay, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal selbst. Und soweit man das mitkriegt, läuft das auch ganz okay. Also das Ziel von einer Million Abonnenten hat man auf jeden Fall jetzt schon geknackt auch. Ja, krass. Und es ist auch gar nicht mal so teuer. Also ich glaube, man zahlt 15 Euro pro Monat. Also im Vergleich zu dem, was man jetzt in anderen Ländern für Fußballspiele bezahlt, finde ich, das ist auch ein ganz akzeptabler Preis. Aber es gibt auch noch Probleme. Also man kann zum Beispiel mal nur acht von neun Spielen gucken, weil ein Spiel noch mit Exklusivrechten bei BIN, meine ich, liegt. Da befinden sich auch alle wieder im Streit darum, dass man das eigentlich zurückhaben will oder BIN will das eigentlich auch nicht haben, aber will eine Entschädigung dafür bekommen oder irgendwie so. Aber es ist, glaube ich, zumindest ein ganz interessanter Schritt und es läuft jetzt auch nicht so ganz schlecht, auch wenn man das jetzt natürlich nach ein paar Monaten noch nicht final sagen kann, ob das jetzt wirklich die Lösung für die Zukunft ist.
Ja, aber interessant. Bernie?
Ja, um eine kleine Lanze für die Spanier zu brechen, was die Auslandsspiele betrifft. Also es ist jetzt zumindest schon schön zu sehen, dass eben dieses geplante Villareal-Wasserspiel in Miami am Ende dann daran gescheitert ist, dass das wirklich der Aufruhr der Fans und teilweise ja auch der Spieler so groß war. Wenn wir nach Italien schauen, da ist immer noch Milan gegen Cormo. Da ist Perth als Austragungsort im Gespräch eben in Australien. Und das Ding ist noch nicht vom Tisch. Also es könnte sein, dass dieses Spiel wirklich im Februar in Perth stattfindet. Kleiner Hintergrund nur dazu, Milan kann dann nicht in San Siro rein, weil die Olympischen Winterspiele da in Italien sind, da die Eröffnungsfeier stattfindet. Also wollte ich nur kurz einbringen, dass zumindest da der spanische Druck dann so groß jetzt schon wurde oder war, dass das Ganze schon vom Tisch genommen wurde, während es in Italien noch auf dem Tisch liegt.
Wobei das Interessante ist, der Veranstalter, also Relevant, das ist die Vermarktungsagentur, die dieses Spiel stattfinden lassen wollte. Die vermarkten übrigens auch die Champions League für die UEFA und so weiter und so fort. Gibt es auch eine Klage zwischen Relevant und UEFA? Ich verlinke mal den Sport Inside Podcast dazu. Da gab es jetzt gerade eine aktuelle Folge genau zu diesen beiden Spielen, wie Real gegen Barca und Milan gegen Como in Australien bzw. den USA, dass Relevant dieses Spiel abgesagt hat, aus wahrscheinlich eben auch marktwirtschaftlichen Gründen. Also es war wohl nicht nur der Protest, aber vielleicht auch, kann man nicht so genau sagen. Aber sehr, sehr interessante Entwicklung auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, wir könnten da noch ewig darüber diskutieren, auch so wie es in den eigenen Ländern aussieht, und das mit den Abos finde ich auch hochinteressant, Jakob. Ich habe ja sehr viele Sendungen schon zu TV-Übertragungsrechten und so weiter gemacht. Und ich weiß, dass in der Bundesliga viele, also diejenigen, die des französischen Mächtigs sind, die gucken aber sehr genau auf die Liga, wie das läuft mit diesem Abomodell. Da muss ich mal wieder meine Drähte heiß laufen lassen, will mal wissen, was die dazu denken. Also wir sehen, es ist nicht ganz so einfach, und das merken wir in der Liga, aber wir haben ja auch noch ein paar andere Ligen, die wir hier besprechen wollen. Chris, wenn du magst, dann das du mal weiter machen. Da haben wir einen deutschen Trainer, für den läuft es allerdings nicht so gut in der Premier League.
Genau, Daniel Fahke bei Leeds United haben am Sonntag 1 zu 2 gegen ersten Villa verloren. Es war die dritte Niederlage in Folge und die fünfte aus den letzten sechs Spielen, damit Platz 18 und man merkt, dass Leeds und vor allem Daniel Fahke jetzt allmählich gehörig unter Druck geraten. Am Sonntag im Stadion gab es zwar auch viel Applaus für Daniel Fahke, aber man hat gemerkt, dass die Stimmung auch zu kippen droht. Es gab auch einige Gesänge in seine Richtung, You Don't Know What You're Doing und es musste auch ein Fan eskortiert werden, der versuchte, Daniel Fahke zu konfrontieren. Man merkt momentan, es ist Krisenstimmung und da muss jetzt schleunigst etwas passieren.
Aber wie würdest du denn das bewerten? Du bist jetzt ja nicht in der emotionalen Situation, Leeds-Fan zu sein und Daniel Fahke konfrontieren zu wollen. Die sind Aufsteiger und da überrascht es einen ja jetzt nicht komplett, dass die auch mal eine sportliche Krise haben und jetzt aktuell auf dem drittletzten Platz liegen, aber ja auch noch punktgleich mit West Ham auf Rang 17. Also wie überrascht bist du denn von dieser Entwicklung?
Das ist der Punkt. Was war die Erwartungshaltung? Also wir schauen auf die letzten zwei Spielzeiten, da sind alle sechs Aufsteiger abgestiegen. Es ist enorm schwer als Aufsteiger in der Premier League Fuß zu fassen. Und wie so oft liegt die Antwort so ein bisschen in der Mitte. Man hat jetzt zwar im Sommer 100 Millionen in den Kader investiert, aber nur 20 Millionen in die Offensive. Und die Offensive ist auch das große Problemkind, die zweitwenigsten Tore erzielt. Und dabei ist man in Sachen Expected Goals im Mittelfeld. Das heißt, es liegt wirklich vorne an der Abschlusswäsche, an der Qualität. Meistens ein Indiz dafür. Und generell wurde der Kader im Sommer nicht so gut verstärkt. Viele 20-Millionen-Einkäufe, Bioll in der Innenverteidigung, floggt komplett. Bornau, den wir aus der Bundesliga noch kennen, ist fast nur verletzt. Meccha hat jetzt in den letzten zwei Spielen zwar getroffen, aber ist auch jetzt nicht der Riesenfaktor. Und die größte Enttäuschung ist eigentlich im Tor mit Luca Perri. Den dürfte Jakob kennen von Olympique Lyon. Ist bisher eine absolute Enttäuschung. Man sieht, Fahke hat jetzt nicht den besten Kader, mit dem er arbeiten kann. Man hat oft daneben gelegen. Trotzdem gibt es auch einige Sachen, die die Fahke angekreidet werden.
Ja, also die Offensive, das sieht man wirklich. Vielleicht haben sie auch ein bisschen zu viel Bundesliga gekauft. Also das Bonau von Metja. Ja gut, ich will jetzt hier nicht immer mein Bundesliga-Hate streuen. Das ist ein bisschen zu viel jetzt. Aber also Anton Stach ist die Top-Verpflichtung. Und das ist ja ein Spieler, den schätze ich sehr hoch ein. Jeder, der mal Nationalteams folgen gehört hat, der weiß das. Aber trotzdem hätte ich jetzt gedacht, so auf Premier League-Niveau, ob das wirklich von Beginn an funktioniert, das sehen wir ja eigentlich sehr selten, dass Spieler, die aus der Bundesliga dorthin wechseln, dann gleich richtig einschlagen. Also höchstens vielleicht Miki van de Ven fällt mir da eine jüngere Vergangenheit.
Ja, also er ist wirklich die Top-Verpflichtung des Sommers bisher. Auch eine positive Entwicklung wird jetzt von vielen Leuten in der Startelf gefordert, ist Tanaka, der letztes Jahr, glaube ich, hingewechselt ist, von Düsseldorf. War in der 2. Liga ein Topspieler bei ihnen, wird jetzt auch immer mehr gefordert. Also die zwei sind positive Namen, negativ dagegen. Und was Fahke so ein bisschen angekreidet wird, ist, dass er beispielsweise sehr auf Brendan Aronson setzt. Und das ist momentan das ganz große Thema in Leeds. Es ist schon, es hat schon Überhand genommen. Er ist ein, er spielt auf dem rechten Flügel, ist eher derjenige, der sich über Laufarbeit, Intensität, Defensivbewusstsein definiert. Und das macht er auch wirklich gut und bekommt Sonderlob. Aber vorne fehlt es halt bei ihm, da fehlt es an Dribblingsstärke, an richtiger Entscheidungsfindung. Und er ist so ein bisschen der Prellbock geworden, der Fans. Und Daniel Fager hat ihn aber auch jetzt in Schutz genommen, fand ich auch sehr auffällig, wie sehr er ihn in Schutz genommen hat. Er hat auch betont, wenn die Fans sich nicht so auf ihn einschießen würden, würde er nicht so viele Mental Health Days brauchen. Also hat auch so ein bisschen versucht, davor zu heben, Leute, das sind auch Menschen und die Art und Weise, wie mit ihnen umgegangen wird, ist nicht gerade förderlich und vor allem sehr schädlich für ihre Psyche. Das fand ich sehr auffällig. Aber insgesamt wird Fager oftmals angekreidet, dass er einfach zu sehr an ihm festhält, gerade weil Nionto wieder fit ist, der eine Alternative auf dem Flügel wäre, oder Daniel James, beide saßen auf der Bank, beide sind eigentlich die besseren Flügelspieler, was die Offensivarbeit angeht. Und genauso wird ihm auch immer wieder vorgeworfen, dass er zu spät Auswechslungen tätigt. Und man sieht einfach bei Leeds, dass sie momentan sehr schlecht mit Führungen umgehen. Und es waren jetzt zwei Spiele hintereinander, dass man nach Führung verloren hatte. Das ist zuvor 53 Spiele am Stück nicht passiert, zugegeben. Da ist auch die Championship dabei gewesen, anderes Format, andere Qualität. Aber ich fand es schon auffällig, dass Una Emery nach dem Spiel sagte am Sonntag, dass man merkte, dass Leeds ein bisschen müde war. Und das ist natürlich kein gutes Zeichen. Aber insgesamt würde ich schon sagen, dass Leeds besser spielt, als die Ausbeute bisher ist. Das ist keine Frage. Ich finde, die Kritik rührt eher daher, dass man so ein bisschen Angst hat, jetzt wieder abzustürzen. Aber insgesamt sind die Leistungen schon deutlich besser. Die zwei Spiele gegen Brighton zuletzt und gegen Nottingham, 0-3 und 1-3, die waren unterirdisch. Das war auch nicht das Leeds, das sich Daniel Fakke vorstellt in Sachen Intensität, Physis etc. Aber insgesamt steht man besser da. Nach expected points wäre Leeds 10. Da sieht man, wo der Schuh drückt. Ich habe es schon angesprochen, Expected Goals vorne drin. Dominic Calvert-Lewin war zwischenzeitlich gut eingebunden, aber es fehlen die Tore genauso bei Matcher. Das ist ein Riesenproblem, das hat man im Sommer verpennt, da einem Sturm nachzulegen und auf der anderen Seite in der Defensive. Du hast die drittwenigsten Fehler, die zu schüssen führen, die acht wenigsten Torschüsse kassiert der gesamten Premier League und hast trotzdem die viertmeisten Tore kassiert. Da schaut man dann wie gesagt auf Perry im Tor, der glaube ich den drittschlechtesten oder viertschlechtesten Wert für Post Shot Expected Goals hat. Also er müsste eigentlich viel mehr halten als eigen Stuhl. Da sieht man schon, dass es auch eher eine Qualitätsfrage ist bei Leeds, als eine Trainerfrage meiner Meinung nach zumindest.
Gleichzeitig ist aber jetzt die Situation, wenn man sich den Spielplan anblick, so dass man sagen muss, bisher hat man oft gegen Teams, die zumindest unten drin standen in der Tabelle, gespielt. Also gegen den 15., den 18., den 20., den 18., den 19. Und nochmal den 19. Das erklärt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen die Aufgeregtheit, denn wenn ich jetzt so die nächsten Spiele gucke, Manchester City auswärts, Chelsea zu Hause, Liverpool zu Hause, ja gut, Liverpool auch in der Krise, aber trotzdem halt noch Liverpool, Brentford und Crystal Palace. Und dann haben wir den ganz kurzen Weihnachtsbreak, den es in der Premier League ja gibt. Was ist denn so dein Eindruck? Wird sich das noch wieder einpendeln da, wo Leeds eigentlich spielerisch gerade hingehört? Und das wäre eher so Rang 12, Rang 13 ist es quasi nach Expected Ghost und Expected Ghost Allowed. Du hast ja Expected Point schon genannt, das wäre Rang 10. Also auf jeden Fall nicht so weit unten in der Tabelle. Glaubst du, das ist möglich in den nächsten Wochen?
Es ist möglich, aber wie du sagst, der Spielplan ist nicht auf Haffke Seite und man könnte auch Leeds United ein bisschen, da ist die Stimmung schnell gekippt. Es ist ein schwieriges Umfeld als Trainer, die Erwartungshaltung ist dort hoch. Was ein bisschen Hoffnung macht, ist gerade die Niederlage am Wochenende paradoxerweise, denn es war eine deutliche Leistungssteigerung im Vergleich zu den zwei Spielen zuvor. Und das ist natürlich ein wichtiges Zeichen, dass Haffke die Truppe noch erreicht. Es war weder in Sachen Physis, Intensität, die Basics, die waren wieder zurück und man hatte Villa eigentlich gut im Griff. Man hatte sehr viele Ballgewinne. Aber man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass Villa einfach auch sehr viel Qualität hat. Da kam ein Malen von der Bank, der hat ein herausragendes Spiel gemacht. Morgan Rogers hat den Ausgleich erzielt und dann noch ein fabelhaftes Freistoß-Tor. Das sind halt Unterschiedsspieler, die Leeds nicht hat. Und da hat Leeds dann einfach das Nachsehen. Und wenn wir dann jetzt auf die nächsten Spiele gucken, du hast es gesagt, da kommen jetzt drei Mannschaften mit einer absurden individuellen Stärke. Da wird es eng. Und ich habe es schon angesprochen. Ich sehe eher die Qualität des Kaders als Problem. Und jetzt wird es halt darauf ankommen, wie kann Fahke Leeds durch diese schwierige Phase in den nächsten Wochen durchführen oder begleiten? Ich glaube, er hat das Zeug dazu, Leeds zu retten. Ich glaube, die Kritik bei ihm rührt auch so ein bisschen daher, dass er sich in der Premier League noch nie so wirklich durchsitzen konnte. Aber wie du sagst, die nächsten drei Spiele, die werden schon entscheidend sein. Und wenn du da zwei Klatschen kassierst und eine knappe Niederlage, dann hilfst auch nichts, dass du irgendwie besser gespielt hast zuletzt oder sonst was. Dann werden sich die Führungspersonen gezwungen, sie zu handeln. Also es wird wirklich drauf ankommen, ob man vielleicht ein kleines Erfolgserlebnis feiern kann. Gerade Liverpool würde sich ja gerade anbieten. Wir haben schon darüber gesprochen, dass man da vielleicht auch so ein Achtungserfolg setzt und das dann nochmal beflügelt und Selbstbewusstsein gibt. Aber ja, es wird komplett drauf ankommen, die nächsten drei Wochen laufen, denke ich. Weil Weihnachten, Winter ist natürlich auch eine beliebte Zeit, um den Trainer zu wechseln.
Vielleicht hilft es ja sogar, dass es jetzt drei Gegner sind, bei denen man nicht davon ausgeht, dass Leeds irgendwas mitnimmt und man dann vielleicht mit einem Punkt, den du da rausholst, dann schon vielleicht so eine kleine Umkehr, zumindest stimmungstechnisch, schaffen kann. Also das ist die Situation bei Daniel Fakir und Leeds United. Dann wollen wir mal eine Positivgeschichte abgreifen. Dafür gehen wir nach Italien. Und wer sich die Serie A-Tabelle zuletzt mal so angeguckt hat, Christian, der hat gesehen, oh, da stehen ja gar nicht Napoli oder Inter oben dran, sondern von der Tabellenspitze grüßt uns die Roma. Und du darfst uns jetzt erklären, wie konnte denn das passieren?
Sehr gerne. Ja, erst mal anfangs. Also es ist wieder sehr, sehr eng in Italien an der Tabellenspitze. Die ersten fünf sind nur noch drei Punkte getrennt. Also das ist einfach sehr eng. Aber es ist wunderbar, wie du sagst, dass die Roma auf eins steht. Das gab es länger nicht mehr. Und ja, das hat logischerweise sehr viel mit Herrn Gasperini zu tun, der ja im Sommer übernommen hat, nach neun Jahren bei Atalanta. Und ich muss sagen, jetzt weg auch von den Punkten. Da kommen wir eh drauf. Also sie stehen ja super da. Aber was mich am meisten beeindruckt hat, also wir kennen ja alle oder viele kennen den Gasperini-Stil. Also dieses Mann orientierte, mutige, nach vorne verteidigende. Das war ja in den letzten Jahren nicht unbedingt in der DNA der Roma veranlagt. Also es gab ja die Mourinho-Jahre, es gab jetzt das kurze Juric sozusagen Intermezzo. Auch Ranieri hat viel auf eine stabile Defensive gesetzt zuletzt. Es war erfolgreich. Aber der Fußball, den Gasperini eben bringt, das ist ja schon ein anderer. Und ich war überrascht und bin es immer noch, wie schneller es geschafft hat, wirklich diese neuen Prinzipien sozusagen der Mannschaft mitzugeben. Die Mannschaft, du merkst das, von Woche zu Woche sind total überzeugt davon, also wie die durchschieben, wie die nach vorne verteidigen. Also das hat man schon nach wenigen Spielen gesehen. Dieser Gasperini-Geist war extrem schnell da. Sie haben die zweitmeisten Ballerobungen im letzten Spielfeld-Drittel. Also sie spielen jetzt diesen Gasperini-Stil schon. Sie haben die meisten Ballerobungen im Mittelfeld in der Serie A. Und ich habe mir den, können wir endlich wieder mal auspacken, den PPDA-Wert oder PPDA oder wie man ihn nennen wollte. Da ist die Roma halt auch wenig überraschend auf Platz 2, also 7,8. Das heißt, die lassen nur knapp 8 Pässe zu, bevor sie eben ins Pressing gehen. Also der PPDA-Wert sagt so ein bisschen was über die Intensität des Pressings aus. Und da ist die Roma einfach schon total eine Gasperini-Mannschaft. Und jetzt kommt der entscheidende Punkt. Obwohl sie so mutig nach vorne verteidigen, haben sie erst sechs Gegentore in zwölf Spielen kassiert. Also es ist mit Arsenal der Top-Wert in ganz Europa. Bei allen Top-5-Ligen, Arsenal hat auch nur sechs kassiert. Und wenn du das jetzt hochrechnst, wenn du halt im Schnitt pro Spiel nur 0,5 Tore kassierst, und du aber diese aggressive Weise hast und dir viele hohe Ballgewinne holst, dann bist du extrem gefährlich. Und deswegen, die Roma ist wirklich jetzt schon eine Gasperini-Mannschaft.
Und glaubst du, dass sich das auch halten kann? Denn du hast den Spielstil jetzt beschrieben, und das ist zu der offensiven Gefahr, also die Roma hat in allen Pflichtspielen in dieser Saison immer erst drei Spiele, in denen man den Goalswert von kleiner als einem Tor hatte. Dazu kommt auch eine defensive Stärke mit dazu. Wenn ich mir jetzt aber Expected Goals und Expected Goals Against ansehe, dann ist man da nicht an der Tabellenspitze. Da ist es eher so Rang 6, Rang 7 im Liga-Vergleich. Ist aber natürlich auch nur eine Statistik. Manchmal gleicht sich das an. Und manchmal kommen wir aber aus so einer Saison raus und können dann ja auch begründen, warum es trotz der Statistik dann oft anders lief. Also es ist halt auch schwierig, gegen diese Roma zu spielen, will ich damit zum Beispiel sagen.
Genau, aber gut, Max, dass du es ansprichst. Ich wollte nämlich auch, das nehme ich wirklich ganz speziell, gerade das Expected Goals Against. Also ich habe es gerade gesagt, die Roma hat sechs Gegentore kassiert und Expected Goals Against haben sie aber 14. Das heißt, sie haben acht weniger kassiert, als sie eigentlich statistisch hätten kassieren sollen. Und da kommen wir jetzt bei einem Mann, der da eine große Rolle dabei spielt, nämlich Miles Villa, der Torhüter. Sie haben zur Erinnerung, der war letztes Jahr schon Torhüter der Saison in der Serie A. Und der hat ihnen auch in der Saison wahnsinnig viele Punkte schon gerettet. Gerade beim Spielstand von 0-0, das beste Beispiel jetzt am Wochenende. Die Roma hat den Cremona gespielt bei Comanese, Aufsteiger, gewinnt am Ende 3-1, souverän. Aber beim 0-0 hält's Villa einen Alleingang. Und solche Szenen gab es einige in dieser Saison, was eben auch zeigt, dass dieses extrem aggressives System von Gasperini nach wenigen Monaten noch nicht komplett implementiert sein kann. Also es gibt immer wieder mal Lücken für einen Gegner. Aber da ist Villa wirklich herausragend. Der hat Goals prevented von 5. Also allein 5 Gegentore hat er sozusagen verhindert. 5 dieser 8 Gegentore. Und es ist wirklich, da kann man die Spiele durchgehen. Es gibt fast in allen Spielen mindestens ein, zwei große Villa-Momente. Aber wie gesagt, das ist nicht ein Momentaufnahme. Villa hat es in der letzten Saison auch schon gezeigt. Also da steckt wirklich individuelle Qualität dahinter. Und um nochmal, jetzt haben wir viel über Systeme oder über Statistiken geredet. Das beleben Gott sei Dank die Spieler, dieses System. Und da können wir vielleicht ein paar rausnehmen. Soleil spielt überragende Saison vorne drin. 5 Tore, schon zwei Vorlagen. Also der junge Argentinier ist wirklich so der Kreative, auch abschlussstark. Koné, da haben wir ja mit Jakob schon das letzte Mal darüber geredet. Also was Koné macht, ist herausragend. Also dass die Roma eben erst 6 Gegendtore kassiert hat, hängt logischerweise nicht nur ans Fila und in der Abwehr, sondern eben auch daran, dass Koné und Cristante da im Zentrum extrem gut zu machen. Ich glaube, es gab ja im England mal den Spruch, oder vor ein paar Jahren, wie die Welt ist von 80 Prozent von Wasser bedeckt und den Rest deckt ein Golo Kante ab. Das war ja mal so ein Ding. Das kann man mittlerweile wirklich auf Koné auch übertragen. Also was der abläuft, was der Ballgewinne hat, was der mit seiner physischen Dominanz da einfach im Zentrum macht. Das ist einfach nur herausragend. Dazu treffen die Schienenspieler von Gasperini. Das ist ja auch immer ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch bei Atalanta, was da Robin Gosens gemacht hat, der da mal zweistellig getroffen hat. Also die Schienenspieler bei Gasperini sind ja auch ein wichtiger offensiver Faktor. Und da ist jetzt Wesley eben, der Brasilianer, den sie geholt haben, der trifft regelmäßig. Der spielt jetzt auf links. Selig, der Türke hat jetzt auf rechts auch getroffen. Also es sind schon viele Sachen da, die eine Gasperini-Mannschaft einfach ausmachen. Und dass das so schnell ging, das ist wirklich, muss ich sagen, hat mich überrascht. Aber wenn sie so weitermachen und wirklich diese defensive Stabilität, also Stabilität plus viel weiter aufrechterhalten können, also nochmal nur kurzes Rechenbeispiel. Wenn ich im Schnitt pro Spiel nur 0,5 Tore kassiere, dann brauche ich auch offensiv gar nicht so viel, um meine Spiele zu gewinnen. Und die Roma kreiert aber eben vieles, hast du ja gesagt, wir dürfen nicht vergessen. Die Roma hat schon 4 Elfmetern diese Saison verschossen. Drei allein in diesem verrückten Lilspiel, drei hintereinander da, wo der Torhüter zweimal nicht auf der Linie stand und dann alle drei verschossen wurden. Gegen Milan im direkten großen Duell, Held Menyar kurz vor Schluss, Elfmeter gegen Dybala. Da hätten sie eigentlich auch einen Punkt holen müssen. Also, ich sage, das Einzige, was dieser Gasperini-Mannschaft noch fehlt, um zu 100% eine Gasperini-Mannschaft zu sein, ist die Offensiven. Er kriegt noch nicht so viel von der Offensive. Das hat auch ein bisschen mit Verletzungsthematiken zu tun. Dovbek ist gerade wochenlang verletzt, Dybala fällt gerade verletzt, Bayley, den sie auch geholt haben aus der Premier League, hat, glaube ich, bis jetzt eineinhalb Spiele gemacht. Also, er hat auch viel mit Verletzungsproblemen gerade und Offensiven zu kämpfen, aber trotzdem steht die Roma auf eins und ist wirklich schon eins zu eins eine Gasperini-Mannschaft. Also wirklich, großes Kompliment hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass sie so schnell diesen Schritt schon gehen.
Chris? Ja, auf die Gefahr hin, zu tief reinzugehen. Ich habe gerade auf den Kader geschaut, da ist der Name Evan Ferguson bei mir rausgeblitzt. Der galt bei Brighton ja als der neue 100-Million-Stürmer vor ein paar Jahren noch. Ich wollte noch fragen, wie es bei ihm aussieht. Er scheint ja auch nicht so richtig zum Zug zu kommen aktuell, oder?
Ja, Chris, guter Punkt. Also, er hat jetzt am Wochenende das erste Tor erzielt, hat es im ersten Mal getroffen. Er war auch– das weißt du ja am besten– der hat die letzte Saison kaum gespielt. Also, der war ja monatelang eigentlich raus. Und deswegen hat Gasperini im Anfang viel spielen lassen, auch aufgrund, weil er eben, wie gesagt, gar nicht so viele Alternativen hatte, hat aber auch gleich gesagt, hey, der braucht noch Zeit. Also, der muss erst wieder in den Rhythmus kommen. Und dann hat er sich auch noch verletzt, hat jetzt zum Beispiel die entscheidenden Irlandspiele verpasst, jetzt in der WM-Quali, und kam jetzt aus dieser Verletzung zurück und macht endlich dieses erste Tor. Das war eine riesen Leichtheit, hat man auch von allen Teamkollegen gesehen, war sehr schön, wie die alle, weil die wissen, der hat dieses Tor gebraucht. Und er ist eigentlich das beste Beispiel dafür, dass die Roma-Offensiven noch gar nicht zünden, aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Dorfbeck hat einmal getroffen, na, Dorfbeck hat glaube ich zweimal getroffen, Dybala einmal und Ferguson einmal, und trotzdem ist die Roma da oben. Also wir können fest davon ausgehen, dass Gasperini auch die Offensiven wieder auf Spur bringt, weil das ist ja eigentlich die Königsdisziplin, die ja ja schon seit Jahren bei Talanta. Also ihr erinnert euch noch, das waren ja zuletzt nicht nur die Skamakas und Decetelaris und Lukmans, das war ja davor auch Zapata und so. Alle Stürmer von Gasperini haben getroffen. Deswegen, ich glaube, das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis das kommt. Und umso bemerkenswerter ist das, dass es jetzt schon funktioniert. Der letzte Punkt noch dazu, darf man schon auch nicht vergessen, es lief ja in der Rückrunde der letzten Saison auch schon. Also da war ja Ranieri, ihr erinnert euch wahrscheinlich noch, wo die Roma diesen unfassbaren Run hatte. Ranieri hat übernommen, drei Punkte vom Abstieg entfernt und hat die dann noch fast in die Champions League geführt. Ich habe es jetzt extra rausgesucht, das ist wirklich beeindruckend, wenn man sich die Liga-Punkte im Kalenderjahr 2025 anschaut. Also nur das Kalenderjahr. Dann hat die Roma in Italien 10 Punkte mehr, also 76 Punkte aus 32 Spielen, 10 Punkte mehr als Napoli und Inter. Und wenn du es auf ganz Europa drehst, nur Barca hat mehr Punkte geholt im Kalenderjahr 2025. Und die Bayern. Die Bayern haben gleich viele Punkte wie die Roma, haben aber zwei Spiele weniger. Aber das nur, um zu zeigen, wie viel Selbstvertrauen die Roma auch unter Ranieri schon aus dem letzten Jahr mitgenommen hat. Und anscheinend haben sie dieses Selbstvertrauen dazu genutzt, um diese Spielweise von Gasperini jetzt extrem schnell zu implementieren. Und deswegen mittlerweile– ich hätte am Anfang der Saison gedacht, ja gut, die Roma ist jetzt da vorne mit dabei. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass die vorne mit dabei bleibt. Weil die einfach schon so stabil sind, weil der Kern schon aus dem letzten Jahr viel, viel gute Erinnerungen hatte und weil die wirklich alle komplett überzeugt davon sind, was die da machen. Letzter Satz dazu. Bisilli, der U21-Nationalspieler, hat gerade ein Interview gegeben, und er hat gesagt, es ist herausragend zu merken, wenn Gasperini in die Kabine kommt, wie schnell der dich davon überzeugt. Dass das, was du zu tun hast, gut für die Mannschaft ist. Und er hat gesagt, das haben alle sofort verstanden. Und du merkst, die sind total überzeugt davon, was die da mit Gasperini machen. Und ich glaube, deswegen sind sie gefährlich.
Chris, ich glaube, ich weiß, was du am Sonntagabend machen wirst. Am 30. November, ab 20.45 Uhr, vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen früher, oder?
Ja, das Roma-Napoli ist am Wochenende. Genau. Und wie gesagt, die Roma eben auch. Milan haben sie in Elfmeter verschossen, gegen Inter haben sie knapp verloren, hätten sie auch nicht verlieren müssen. Waren sie mindestens ebenbürtig. Also die Roma ist eine Realität. Nicht nur, glaube ich, so ein kleines Strohfeuer.
Also, Roma gegen Neapel jetzt eben am Sonntagabend 20.45 Uhr. Und letzter Fun-Fact, die Torhüter Roms scheinen gerade nicht so schlecht zu sein. Denn der einzige, der einen noch besseren Post-Shot-Expected-Goals abgewehrt hat als Israelia, das ist Provendel von Lazio. Also läuft bei den römischen Torhütern aktuell. Dann blicken wir mal noch in die Liga. Jakob, auch du hast uns da schöne Themen mitgebracht. Wollen wir zuerst auch mit einem Titelkampf starten, wenn wir jetzt gerade schon beim Tabellenführer der Serie A waren? Wie sieht es denn da aus? Gibt es denn einen Titelkampf? Also ich habe das Thema gesehen und dachte mir so, hä? Moment, was?
Ja, tatsächlich sieht es ja ein wenig so aus zumindest. Also wir waren jetzt zumindest an zwei Spieltagen.
Wie vorsichtig du schon formulierst, wie stark.
Es könnte sein.
Ja, wir waren jetzt zumindest an zwei Spieltagen in der Situation, dass PSG zumindest während des Spieltags nicht mehr Erster war und dann immer nachziehen musste, weil Olympique Marseille jeweils vorlegen konnte und das auch getan hat und wirklich eine beeindruckende Saison spielt. Also wir hatten ja in der ersten Rasenfunk-Folge dieser Saison schon über sie gesprochen und da war ja eher so das Thema, ja, Stotterstart und Chaos mit Rabiot und Ro, die ja da sich geprügelt hatten und dann noch gegangen sind, kurz vor Ende der Transferphase und es hatte jetzt nicht unbedingt so vieles darauf hingedeutet, dass man jetzt so eine beeindruckende Serie hinlegt. Also es ging dann kurz nach dieser Folge eigentlich schon los, dass man in der Liga gut gewonnen hat, in der Champions League ein überragender Sieg gegen Ajax Amsterdam. Gut, wir haben ja auch mit Daniel häufig über die Probleme bei Ajax gesprochen, aber trotzdem. Dann hatte man eine Phase Ende Oktober, wo man drei Spiele nicht gewonnen hat, unter anderem auch sehr bitter 2 zu 1 in Lens verloren hat, also auch bei dem einzigen Team, was vorne mit PSG und Marseille mithalten kann bisher in der Saison. Und dann noch ein Unentschieden gegen Angers, aber ansonsten hat man seitdem auch in der Liga wieder alle Spiele gewonnen und auch in der Champions League gegen Atalanta unglücklich verloren, will ich es mal nennen, wenn man das gesehen hat. Also da kann man sich auf jeden Fall das Tor von Atalanta gerne noch mal angucken, eine sehr kuriose Szene, nämlich erst Handspiel im Atalanta-Strafraum Marseille reklamiert und fängt sich wirklich im direkten Gegenzug das 1 zu 0 durch ein schönes Tor von Samadžić. Dementsprechend war man da natürlich auch nicht so richtig begeistert. Aber wir hatten ja auch schon angerissen, dass sie jetzt in dieser Woche auch in der Champions League gewonnen haben. Ein sehr wichtiger Sieg mit 2 zu 1 gegen Newcastle, die ja auch mit durchaus Rückenwind aus dem Wochenende eigentlich kamen, da sie ja gegen City gewonnen hatten. Also den Erfolg sollte man auch wirklich nicht unterschätzen zu Hause. Und das war auch meiner Meinung nach zumindest nicht unverdient. Also sie haben da schon auch ein ganz gutes Spiel gemacht. Und so sieht es jetzt momentan echt gut aus. Ich habe auch eine Statistik mitgebracht. Man hat nämlich in 2.25.26 auch hinter Barca und Bayern die meisten Tore geschossen in den Top-5-Ligen. Also gerade in der Offensive läuft es wirklich extrem gut. Man hat 33 Tore schon geschossen in nur 13 Spielen. Und da können wir natürlich auch mal drauf schauen, wer da so verantwortlich ist in der Offensive dafür. Und da ist natürlich zuerst ein Rückkehrer nach Marseille mit Pierre-Emerick Aubameyang. Und ja, der ist schon 36. Und ich dachte im Sommer, okay, es ist vielleicht ein ganz netter Transfer, weil der so ein bisschen wie man es bei dem Transfer von Giroud zu Lille gedacht hatte, ja, der wird dann den jüngeren Stürmern sicherlich helfen. Ist von der Bank bestimmt eine nette Option. Jetzt ist er aber gerade in den letzten Wochen Startspieler, hat in 16 Spielen wettbewerbsübergreifend 16 Torbeteiligungen gemacht. Und das Ganze auch in nur 1.100 Minuten ungefähr. Also wirklich eine beeindruckende Saison von ihm. Und er hat sich auch gar nicht so verändert als Spielertyp. Also er hat natürlich nicht mehr diese absurde Endgeschwindigkeit, die er vor zehn Jahren oder so hatte. Aber er ist immer noch ein wahnsinnig guter Torjäger und kann aber auch einfach richtig stark mitspielen. Also er passt da wirklich sehr gut ins System. Taktisch kann man sagen, dass es so ein relativ typischer Dessert-Spielstil auch weiterhin ist. Das heißt, man baut von ganz tief aus dem eigenen Strafraum auf, versucht den Gegner anzulocken und dann halt überfallartig das Pressing dann auszuspielen. Gerne auch mal mit einem langen Ball durchaus. Da ist Aubameyang auch ein ganz wichtiger Faktor im Festmachen der Bälle und dann neben Weiterleiten auf die offensiven Außenbahnen. Und so funktioniert das momentan dann gerade offensiv halt wirklich gut. Also ich glaube, Konter beziehungsweise so ist es dann ja kein richtiger Konter, sondern so eine Art künstlicher Konter, den man erzeugt durch diese Spielweise. Und in solchen Situationen ist Marseille schon mit das Beste, was man in Europa, glaube ich, momentan angucken kann. Und das funktioniert dann schon echt beeindruckend. Und flankiert wird Aubameyang in der Offensive jetzt in den letzten Wochen meistens auf links von Igor Pai-Schao, der im Sommer ja für sehr viel Geld für französische Verhältnisse hat, glaube ich, 35 Millionen gekostet von Feyenoord und war erst verletzt und macht sich jetzt in den letzten Wochen aber immer besser, hat jetzt noch nicht die super Zahlen. Ich finde aber gerade, wenn man die Spiele über 90 Minuten sieht, macht er einen sehr guten Eindruck, gerade weil er auch gegen den Ball viel arbeitet. Also in den Verteidigungsphasen hilft er gerne auch mal so als eine Art linker Wingback aus und es ist generell viel zu finden. Ich glaube, das mögen dann auch gerade die Trainer wirklich sehr gerne. Und nach vorne hat er jetzt auch schon einzelne Glanzmomente zumindest. Und auf rechts kommen wir dann auch nicht drum hin, über Mason Greenwood zu sprechen. Da müssen wir natürlich voranstellen nochmal, dass er ja nicht ohne Grund nicht mehr in England spielt, nicht mehr bei Manchester United spielt, sondern ja, es Vorwürfe und eine Anklage wegen Vergewaltigungsvorwürfen gegen ihn gab. Er wurde ja nicht freigesprochen, sondern die Anklage wurde zurückgezogen, weil die Hauptzeugen oder Hauptzeuginnen ihre Aussagen zurückgezogen haben und das Verfahren dann eingestellt wurde. Aber Manchester United hat ja trotzdem klargemacht, hier bei uns wirst du nicht mehr spielen. Auch in der englischen Nationalmannschaft spielte er nicht mehr. Er hat dann ja eine Saison auf Leihbasis bei Getafe gespielt und ist dann vor der letzten Saison zu Marseille gewechselt. Da gab es auch anfangs durchaus große Proteste aus der Fanszene und auch der Bürgermeister von Marseille hatte irgendwie gesagt, dass er dem auch nicht so gut gesinnt gegenüberstehen würde. Und das hat sich jetzt in den letzten Jahren oder seitdem er da ist, aber auch ein bisschen verflüchtigt. Das ist jetzt nicht mehr so viel Thema in der Medienberichterstattung, auch wenn es immer mal wieder hochkommt, je nachdem, wo man das liest auf jeden Fall. Es war jetzt gerade vor dem Newcastle-Spiel auch noch mal Thema, weil es das erste Mal war, dass er wieder gegen ein englisches Team gespielt hat. Und es ist zumindest in England, glaube ich, auch– ich habe das zumindest bei der L'Equipe gelesen– leise Überlegungen von Anhängern der Nationalmannschaft gab, ob er nicht ein Thema für die WM werden könnte aufgrund seiner sportlichen Leistungen. Soweit ich das gehört habe, hat Thomas Tuchel sich aber auch geäußert, dass das nicht in Frage käme, also dass er nicht mehr für die Nationalmannschaft spielen würde. Dahingehend hat Greenwood auch überlegt, ob er nicht für Jamaika spielen könnte. Das ist aber alles noch nicht ganz geklärt, wie das vonstatten gehen könnte. Also ich glaube, es ist auf jeden Fall wichtig, dass man dieses Thema jetzt, wenn man über ihn spricht, nicht außen vor lässt. Man muss allerdings sagen, rein sportlich spielt er eine grandiose Saison, hat auch schon in der letzten Saison wirklich eine gute Runde gespielt, hatte da, glaube ich, auch über 20 Tore und Assists kumuliert. Jetzt in dieser Saison steht er in der Liga bei 10 Toren und drei Assists. Und er ist ein wirklich starker Spieler. Es macht Spaß, ihm beim Fußballspielen zuzugucken. Er ist extrem beidfüßig, einer der beidfüßigsten Spieler, die es momentan gibt in Europa. Er ist super stark im Abschluss überperformt, auch seine Expected Goals ein wenig, ist aber, glaube ich, einer der Spieler, bei denen man auch durchaus erwarten kann, dass sich das nicht unbedingt wieder einpendelt. Also seine Abschlussqualität ist einfach gerade auch aufgrund dieser Beidfüßigkeit so hoch, dass das nicht unbedingt ein Ausreißer sein muss. Und damit ist er einfach für Marseille wirklich auch in der Offensive ein wahnsinnig wichtiger Faktor dann.
Und wenn dann noch in der Defensive Benjamin Pavard noch mit dazukommt, ja, Perlei von Inter, der auch, so wie ich es jetzt sehe, hier fast jede Minute gespielt hat, na, wobei 13 Spiele hat er von Beginn an gemacht. Aber nach Minuten ist er der viert-meist eingesetzte Spieler bei Marseille. Da kommt viel zusammen, ja, total interessant, wie sich das gedreht hat bei Olympique. Christian, du wolltest noch was sagen?
Ja, ganz kurz, ich glaube, was man der Zerby auch sehr positiv anheften muss, ist Rabiot, also die Art und Weise, wie er Rabiot verloren hat, ist ja total kurios. Also wir kennen ja Geschichte, da gab es ja diese körperliche Auseinandersetzungen in der Kabine, wenn es die nicht gegeben hätte. Also Rabiot ist ein unfassbar wichtiger Spieler für diese Mannschaft. Ich habe es mir noch mal angeschaut, der hat in der letzten Saison neun Ligatore gemacht für Marseille. Und der ist ja nicht nur anhand seiner Tore wichtig für eine Mannschaft, sondern aufgrund der Balance, die er in der Mannschaft gibt, sage ich nur Stichwort Milan, schau dir an, was der bei Milan jetzt eben reinbringt. Und dass der Zerbi so einen Spieler sozusagen verlieren muss, obwohl das hatte ja keine Transfer, das hatte ja keine, wir müssen den verkaufen, wir wollen den verkaufen. Und dann trotzdem so schnell wieder das Gleichgewicht findet, so schnell die Balance findet und eben so einen wichtigen Spieler so ersetzen kann, finde ich, spricht auch für den Zerbi.
Auf jeden Fall, ja. Es ist auch interessant im Mittelfeld, weil ich finde, dieses Vakuum auf der 10, was Fabio hinterlassen hat, ist auch eins, was man nicht so direkt geschlossen hat oder noch nicht direkt hat schließen können. Man hat da zwar relativ viele Spieler schon ausprobiert, also unter anderem auch zwei junge Spieler mit Rubinho Vaz und Daryl Bacolar, der jetzt auch in der Champions League das Tor von Aubameyang beispielsweise vorbereitet hat in seinem ersten Startelf-Einsatz für Marseille mit 17 Jahren. Also da auch durchaus beeindruckend. Und dann hat man auch André Gomez noch ausprobiert oder Matt O'Reilly, der kurz vor Transfer-Schluss noch von Brighton gekommen ist. Da hat sich jetzt aber noch niemand so richtig festgespielt. Da bin ich ganz gespannt, wie sich das jetzt in den nächsten Wochen noch entwickeln wird. Ein Spieler, der aber im Mittelfeld auf jeden Fall noch eine sehr große Rolle spielt, ist Arthur Vermeeren, der ja kurz vor Transfer-Schluss aus Leipzig noch ausgeliehen wurde bisher auch nur. Aber der spielt wirklich eine ganz wichtige Rolle. Also ist so ein bisschen das Metronom bei Marseille im Mittelfeld auch ein Spielertyp, der ihnen glaube ich vorher durchaus fehlte, weil sie ja ansonsten auf der Sechs zum Beispiel mit Heubierk und Condogbia jetzt eher so den Typ Abräumer haben. Also zumindest kein Day, wo man jetzt sagen kann, okay, der ist technisch so stark, dass er in so einem Deserby-System wirklich den Ball auch mal annehmen, mit dem Rücken zum Tor, sich unter Druck aufdrehen kann und dann weitergeben kann. Und da ist Vermeeren wirklich enorm wichtig und auch gegen den Ball spielt er eine sehr interessante Rolle. Da gab es jetzt zum Beispiel in der Liga gegen Nizza zu sehen, dass Angel Gomez eigentlich nominell auf der Zehn gespielt hat, aber gegen den Ball dann immer die Position mit Vermeeren getauscht hat, sodass Vermeeren dann vorne mit Aubameyang, der erste Anlaufspieler, war. Also da sieht man schon, wie viel de Serbi auch auf Vermeeren setzt und wie wichtig der jetzt schon geworden ist in der kurzen Zeit, die er da ist.
Er kommt vermehrt zum Einsatz und führt eben dazu, dass Marseille gemeinsam mit Lance, über die wir ja auch schon gesprochen haben in der Liga Tour, zwei Punkte hinter PSG liegt. Und wenn ich mir so die nächsten Spiele anschaue von Olympique, dann klar gibt es da auch Stolpersteine, also auswärts in Lille zum Beispiel könnte schwierig werden. Oder Monaco, die, wenn man sich da mal Expected Goals werde anguckt, grotesk unterperformen. Aus verschiedensten Gründen haben wir hier ja auch schon angesprochen. Aber insgesamt sieht das schon alles sehr, sehr machbar aus. Und könnte vielleicht wirklich sein, dass der Serbier es schafft, damit Olympique dran zu bleiben an PSG. Und dann wird es irgendwann im Februar zum direkten Duell kommen. Und das Hinspiel hat man ja schon gewonnen. Das ist ja quasi Teil des sehr, sehr guten Saisonstarts bisher von Olympique, dass man auch PSG einmal 1 zu 0 besiegen konnte damals. Das war das verschobene Spiel, glaube ich, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere.
Ja, genau. Um einen Tag.
Genau. Das war ja… Also, schauen wir mal, wie es da weitergeht. Schon interessant, wir haben jetzt nach Gasperini schon den zweiten Trainer, wo man sagt, steht für einen klaren Stil, steht auch für einen Offensivstil, kommt zu einem Team und schafft es dann doch entgegen der Erwartung, aus unterschiedlichen Gründen jetzt hier das zu implementieren. Finde ich ganz interessant. Dann lass uns mal nochmal zwei schnellere Runden machen. Fabian, du durftest jetzt schon ganz lange nichts mehr sagen. Ich hoffe, dein Mund ist nicht zu trocken geworden. Worüber können wir denn noch sprechen, wenn wir auf La Liga blicken, wenn wir nicht nur so riesige Themen wie wie geht es dem spanischen Fußball generell aufmachen?
Nein, nein, nein, um Gottes Willen, ich möchte euch heute mal ein Team vorstellen, das vielleicht, das wir, glaube ich, noch nie besprochen haben und das aber eine sehr interessante Entwicklung im Moment nimmt. Das war der FC Elche. Das ist schon ein spanischer Traditionsclub, den aber wahrscheinlich die wenigsten kennen. Es ist eigentlich so eine traditionelle Fahrstuhlmannschaft, immer wieder zwischen erster und zweiter Liga hin und her pendelt. Aber sie haben seit 2019 eine sehr interessante Entwicklung genommen, nämlich da sind drei argentinische Fußballer eingestiegen und haben den Verein gekauft, beziehungsweise halten, glaube ich, 90 Prozent der Aktienanteile. Allen voran ist da der Argentinier Christian Bragarnik und er hält es zusammen mit Gustavo Bu und Dario Benedetto. Sie sind jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht die bekanntesten argentinischen Spieler, aber sie haben auf jeden Fall diesen Club zusammen gekauft. Und seitdem geht es bei Elche sportlich ordentlich bergauf, also sie machen einen richtig guten Job. Sie haben den Verein in der 2. Liga übernommen, haben dann relativ schnell den Aufstieg geschafft, sind aber leider im Folge ja gleich wieder abgestiegen und haben dann in der 2. Liga einen Trainer verpflichtet und mit dem hat sich das Blatt ein bisschen zum Positiven gewendet, nämlich Eder Saravia, ein sehr interessanter Trainer und der sticht so ein bisschen in die Kerbe von den offensiven Trainern, wie wir es gerade aus Marseille oder Rom gehört haben. Denn das ist einer dieser Trainer, der lieber 5 zu 4 gewinnt, würde ich jetzt einfach mal behaupten, statt 1 zu 0, der egal, was die Qualität seiner Mannschaft anbelangt, ihnen vermittelt, mit Ballbesitz, mit Mut nach vorne zu spielen. Und das hat unter anderem auch Real Madrid am Wochenende feststellen müssen, die ganz knapp an der Niederlage waren. Da hat Elche zweimal geführt gegen die Königlichen, die dann am Schluss noch etwas glücklich ausgleichen konnten. Aber man sieht schon, was da gemacht wird, und zwar ordentliche Arbeit. Und Eder Saravia, der Trainer, war lange Jahre Co-Trainer von Quique Setién. Der ist im Moment zwar in Spanien nicht mehr aktiv, ist aber sehr erfolgreich gewesen bei Las Palmas. Da war Co-Trainer Saravia, dann bei Betis Sevilla und dann eben beim FC Barcelona. Und dementsprechend hat er auch so ein bisschen was von der Barcelona, von der Masiya-Schule, so ein bisschen mit dabei. Und seine erste eigene Trainerstation von Eder Saravia war dann Andorra in der dritten Liga. Die hat er dann hochgeführt in die zweite Liga. Das ist der Piquet-Club, der kleine König-Starter, jetzt in den Pyrenäen. Und genau, und wurde dann, obwohl er mit Andorra, bei Andorra dann in der zweiten Saison entlassen wurde, weil die waren dann relativ weit unten. Und wie gesagt, er verzichtet nicht auf seinen offensiven Spielstil, egal wie die Ergebnisse sind, hat ihn dann Elche verpflichtet. Und seitdem geht es bei Elche richtig, richtig gut zur Sache. Und sehr, ein sehr überraschender Spieler, wie ich finde, den ich da gerne nennen möchte. Den Elche dann schon letztes Jahr in der zweiten Liga geholt hat, unter Sarabia, war der Österreicher David Affengruber. Den hatte ich 0,0 auf dem Schirm. Und für den haben sie aber mal 4 Millionen Euro an Sturm Graz damals überwiesen, was eine ordentliche Summe ist für einen Zweitligisten, wie ich finde. Und der ist sofort zum Abwehrchef geworden. Also der ist wirklich unglaublich, der Mann. Und er hat dann mit seinen jungen Jahren Elche gleich zum Aufstieg verholfen und ist jetzt auch nach wie vor Abwehrchef in der ersten Liga in Spanien. Also der ist wirklich eingeschlagen, wahnsinnig gut eingeschlagen. Ich glaube, er ist noch nicht Nationalspieler, sondern nur 21 Nationalspieler. Das könnte sich demnächst ändern, denke ich mal, bei dem jungen Mann. Und ja, genau, es macht einfach Spaß, Elche beim Fußballspielen zuzugucken. Die Kommunikation auch zwischen Trainer der Presse und der Mannschaft und so weiter ist wirklich sehr, sehr positiv, sehr, wie gesagt, sehr mutiger Fußball. Und er schafft es auch, aus den Spielern was rauszukitzeln. Und da möchte ich auch noch einen Spieler hervorheben, das ist Alex Fabers. Und jetzt kommt der Bezug natürlich zum FC Malaga. Der darf nicht fehlen.
Viel zu lang gedauert.
Ja, viel zu lang. Der hat auch bei uns in der 2. Liga gekickt und der hat davor in Mallorca gekickt, in Saragossa gekickt. Der kommt aus der Jugend von Real Madrid und hat nie den Durchbruch geschafft und hat eigentlich unfassbare Spielanlagen. Ein Tripler, ein Ballstreichler, unwahrscheinlich gute Pässe, Zug nach vorne, kommt oft zum Abschluss, hat aber wahrscheinlich einen miserablen Expected Goal zu welchem gehabt. Hat auf jeden Fall nie den Durchbruch geschafft. Ist immer so zwischen dem Erstligisten, Zweitligisten hin und her getinkt, auch beim FC Malaga. War er zwar Stammspieler, aber hat es auch nicht geschafft, dann wirklich mal Spiele zu entscheiden, obwohl er sich immer wieder ins letzte Drittel vorgetribbelt hat, gute Assists gemacht hat, aber selber im Abschluss eben schwach war. Und der blüht gerade richtig auf, der ist jetzt schon 29, also den hat Zarabiya nochmal richtig gut hinbekommen, hat gegen Real Madrid auch das 1-0 gemacht, ist im Mittelfeld angekommen, sag ich jetzt mal, bei Elche. Und für den freut es mich natürlich ganz besonders, dass der so durchgeschlagen hat. Und es macht einfach Spaß, wie gesagt, Elche anzugucken. Sie finanzieren sich sehr gut, sie haben jetzt zum Beispiel auch in der zweiten Liga ihre besten Spieler verkaufen müssen. Einer ist, glaube ich, noch in New York gegangen, einer nach Mexiko. Haben aber wieder gut reinvestiert und haben auch einen jungen Spanier, einen 20-jährigen Mendoza heißt der, ein Mittelfeldspieler, da ist angeblich Arsenal dran. Also bei Elche läuft gerade vieles richtig. Gutes sportliches Projekt, tolle Stadion, klappt knapp 40.000, Fußballarena, gehört in die Provinz Valencia mit rein, auf dem Schirm haben, da könnte was gehen die nächsten Jahre.
Ja, und vor allem schön, wir haben Anfang Oktober schon mal über Elche gesprochen, da haben wir vor allem über Sarabia gesprochen und eben aus welcher Trainerschule er kommt. Damals war Elche fünfter und wir sehen, es ist jetzt zwar nicht mehr der fünfte Platz, aktuell der zehnte, aber so arg viel schlechter ist es nicht geworden. Also scheint wirklich nachhaltig zu sein und das ist doch schön zu sehen. Und gleichzeitig hast du uns mit dem Stichwort Arsenal auch schon die perfekte Überleitung zu Chris gebaut, denn wir wollen auch noch mal über den FC Arsenal sprechen. Wir haben das 3 zu 1 gegen Bayern mitbekommen, wir wussten aber schon vorher, dass Arsenal gut ist. Unter anderem weißt du, wie oft Chris, ich eigentlich die Statistik von dir im Gespräch mit anderen nochmal zitiert habe, dass Arsenal im Oktober so wenige Torschüsse nur gegen sich zugelassen hat. Und niemand konnte das glauben. Also danke für diesen Fun-Fact, damit sind aber die Stakes jetzt hoch. Du musst jetzt fast wieder was liefern. Also wie läuft es bei Arsenal, wenn wir auch mal Champions League haben, wahrscheinlich jetzt alle mitbekommen. Aber wenn wir auch mal darüber hinausblicken, denn die anderen, die stolpern ja alle, City, Liverpool und so weiter.
Ja, genau. Und anders als in den letzten Jahren nutzt Arsenal das auch einfach aus. Sie haben selbst eine ziemliche Verletzungskrise momentan. Es fehlen die ersten drei Stürmer. Es fehlt Martinelli, kam jetzt zurück, Madrige, Wöhringart, Gabriel, also einiges dabei. Und trotzdem merkt man es der Mannschaft aktuell nicht an. Und das ist auch einfach aufgrund dieser enormen Tiefe, die dieser Kader hat. Das haben wir ja schon vor kurzem schon angesprochen. Und auch einer der Gründe, warum es jetzt besser läuft und nicht mehr so standardlastig ist, ist Eberhecci Ezi, der im Sommer gekommen ist und jetzt allmählich aufblüht. Und ja, am Sonntag im Derby gegen Tottenham. Das war schon fast kitschig, muss man dazu sagen, was Eberhecci Ezi und Arsenal da lebten. Zunächst gab es für englische Verhältnisse zumindest eine ziemlich sehenswerte Choreo. Dann wurde der Erzrivale mit 4-1 abgeschossen und eben auch die Tabellenführung auf sechs Zähler ausgebaut. Und dann auch noch der Hat-Trick für Ezi. Und das Besondere daran ist, dass Eberhecci Ezi ein Kindheits-Arsenal-Fan ist, wurde mit 13 aus der Academy herausgeschmissen übertrieben, aber nicht weiter berücksichtigt. Musste dann über Millwall, QPR und Palace seinen Weg machen. Und im Sommer war er jetzt bereit für den nächsten Schritt. Tottenham galt als sehr interessiert. Man war sich auch schon einig mit Crystal Palace. Und das hat mittlerweile Ateta auch bestätigt. Daraufhin rief Eberhecci Ezi bei Ateta an und hat gefragt, seid ihr nicht auch interessiert? Und dann hat Ateta eine Vorstandssitzung einberufen. Und man hat sich entschieden, Eberhecci Ezi doch zu verpflichten. Und innerhalb von 24 Stunden war das Ding durch.
Das hat er ja gar nicht mitbekommen. Das ist ja völlig irre. Ich wusste natürlich, dass er Jugend-Arsen-Fan ist und so weiter. Und die drei Tore habe ich mitbekommen. Und die Choreo, noch in kleineren Anführungszeichen, aber du hast es ja schon richtig eingeordnet. Das ist ja tatsächlich witzig, dass er Ateta angerufen hat. Und Ateta kann ja sein Glück auch nicht fassen, weil der konnte ja noch nicht ahnen, wie viele Spieler sich verletzen würden und wie wichtig das wäre, dass du gerade jemanden hast, der richtig trifft.
Genau. Also ich glaube auch, dass da vielleicht auch die Verletzung von Keharvets eine Rolle spielte, weil kurz zuvor hat er sich verletzt und ist jetzt auch länger ausgefallen. Und vielleicht hätte man jetzt nicht Ezi verpflichtet, wenn Harvets nicht so lange ausgefallen wäre. Aber es ist nun mal passiert. Und ja, es war schon eine große Sache für Arsene und für Ezi, dass die beiden jetzt wieder zueinander gefunden haben. Die Fans waren begeistert. Für sie war es einer der größten Transfers der letzten Jahre. Und er tat sich am Anfang ein bisschen schwer. Er ist an sich ein sehr emotionaler, zurückhaltender Typ an sich. Und man merkte so, vielleicht ist das Ganze erst mal ein bisschen überwältigend. Und jetzt gegen Tottenham ist der Knoten dann endgültig geplatzt. Ein Hedwig geschossen zum ersten Mal im Northlanden-Darby. Gab es ein Hedwig seit 1978. Und die Tore waren alle recht ähnlich. Die waren so aus knapp 16 Metern, bei denen er nicht mal jäkig schießt, sondern eher, dass dem Ball ins Tor passt. Das finde ich immer so eine Qualität, wenn man sieht, jemand hält nicht voll drauf, sondern er weiß ganz genau, wo er hinsieht und passt dem Ball dann ins Tor. Und man sieht an diesem Spiel abangesehen, dass Essi Asen eine neue Komponente gibt. Denn wir wissen, dass Atetta ein sehr detailversessener Trainer ist, wo alles so seine Strukturen hat. Jeder hat so seine gewisse Rolle. Und Essi ist so ein Spieler, der da ein bisschen herausbricht und so einen Kreativfaktor mitbringt, einen X-Faktor mitbringt und auch mal das tut, was keiner erwartet und losgelöst von seinen Aufgaben sein Instinkt einfach walten lässt. Und ja, man merkt jetzt, dass mit ihm so eine neue neue Kompetente ins Spiel kommt und die Offensive jetzt auch allmählich ein bisschen mehr fließt und trotzdem ist er einfach auch ein sehr defensiv starker Spieler. Das habe ich gegen Tottenham gesehen und das war wieder so eine kleine Erinnerung. Ich musste irgendwie dran denken, als Atetta kam wurde ja Özil aussortiert. Und die sind ja, was Offensivfußball angeht, nicht unähnlich, sage ich mal, nicht jetzt von der Abschlussstärke, aber beide sehr lässig, arrogant, elegante Spieler. Aber im Gegensatz zu Özil arbeitet Esi auch viel nach hinten mit und das ist halt ein Faktor, den Atetta braucht. Wenn du das nicht tust, spielst du nicht. Und dementsprechend funktioniert das Ganze auch gerade so. Auch gestern gegen Bayern, einen tollen Assist gehabt zum 3 zu 1. Also Esi ist jetzt langsam auch angekommen.
Und zeigt ja auch, wie lange Atetta jetzt einfach schon bei Arsenal ist. Bin nur mal kurz zusammengezückt. Ah ja, richtig, stimmt. Genau. Und damals kann sich lohnen, an einem Trainer festzuhalten. Und falls ihr euch gefragt habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie sieht es denn, wie lief denn jetzt der November? Also ein Spiel gibt es noch gegen Chelsea. Das ist auch definitiv jetzt interessant. Nummer eins gegen Nummer zwei jetzt am Sonntagnachmittag. Also 17.30 können wir quasi das Topspiel Premier League angucken und 20.45 Topspiel Serie A. Und wenn ihr euch gefragt habt, wir wissen ja, wie viele Schüsse man im Oktober zugelassen hat. Wie viele wurden es denn jetzt im November? Man braucht zwei Hände, um es zu sagen. Aber es waren acht Schüsse, die Arsene zugelassen hat. In den Spielen gegen Burnley, Slavia Prag, Sunderland, Tottenham und jetzt eben die Bayern. Übrigens Slavia Prag und Bayern jeweils drei Schüsse. Also auf Augenhöhe haben sich die Bayern da präsentiert. Es ist einfach weiter absolut faszinierend. Letzte Frage dazu. So ein bisschen jetzt musst du in die Glaskugel gucken. Aber zieht es Arsene durch? Holen sie den Titel?
Ich glaube ja. Ich glaube, es liegt an zwei Gründen, mache ich das fest. Zum einen Liverpool haben wir darüber gesprochen. Die werden nicht mehr in den Titelkampf finden. Man City ist, was die Qualität des Kaders angeht, nach dem Umbruch auch noch nicht da. Das merkt man. Da kannst du nicht mehr so gut rotieren. Die werden noch weiter Punkte lassen. Chelsea bleibt jetzt abzuwarten. Inwiefern sie das Level halten können, das war immer so das Problem der letzten Jahre. Aber was für Arsene spricht, ist diese absurde Tiefe. Die können jeden Ausfall kompensieren. Gabriel fehlt, Hinkapier macht das, Mosquera macht das. Wenn das so weiter läuft und sie nicht zu sehr von den Verletzungen heimgesucht werden, glaube ich nicht, dass sie großartig nachlassen werden.
Arsene hatte in allen Pflichtspielen in dieser Saison, das müssten 13 gewesen sein, nee, müssten sogar mehr gewesen sein, auf jeden 19 Spiele sind es. Und man hat nur in einem Spiel einen Expected-Goals-Ergänzwert von größer als einem Tor zugelassen. Und das war im allerersten Pflichtspiel diese Saison. Also, wir reden viel über Offensive über Arsene. Lasst die Defensive nicht vergessen. Es ist einfach, es ist fantastisch. Also Arsene thront gerade über der Premier League. Wir haben auch schon Christian über denjenigen gesprochen, der über der Serie A thront. Es gibt aber durchaus noch andere Teams, die da überraschend oben mitmischen. Und über ein solches möchtest du uns noch ein bisschen was erzählen.
Ja, über Bologna und ich glaube, das überraschend muss man streichen, weil das ist halt nicht mehr überraschend, weil die das jetzt schon zum wiederholten Male machen. Also ganz kurz sind auch nur drei Punkte hinter der Tabellenspitze. Es sind fünfter, vierter Punkt gleich mit Inter. Und ja, Vincenzo Italiano hatten wir hier ja auch schon ein, zwei Mal. Also wirklich herausragend, was die weiterhin machen. Bologna spielt hohen Rhythmus, hohe Intensität, hohes Pressing. Ich hatte es ja vorhin mit dem PPDA. Roma ist auf Platz 2 in der Serie A. Bologna ist auf Platz 3, lässt nur 8,5 Pässe zu. Dann gehen die rein, weil die intensiv und mit hohen Pressing spielen. Und sie haben jetzt eine unfassbare, gute Balance gefunden. Denn, vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch, wir haben über Italiano auch gesprochen. Er war ja bei der Fiorentina. Die Fiorentina hat damals zwei Mal ins Conference League Finale geführt, auch ins Coppa Italia Finale. Die haben sie alle verloren, weil es da manchmal defensiv noch ein bisschen naiv war. Das war dann dieses hohe Verteidigen, diesen Durchschieben, war dann in so manchen Momenten, da gab es gerade in den Finals gegen West Ham, glaube ich, war das eine Finale, wo sie dann bei 1-1 in der 88. in der Mittellinie verteidigen und West Ham kommt durch und macht das 2-1. So, und das, da hat sich Italiano extrem weiterentwickelt. Also Bologna verteidigt nicht mehr so naiv. Sie haben jetzt auch die drittbeste Abwehr der Liga. Also, obwohl sie hochpressen, obwohl sie lücken lassen, ist es viel balanciert. Kleiner Fun-Fact auch zum PPDA. Auf Platz 1, wer es schätzt hier, steht in Italien. Also Roma auf 2, Bologna auf 3.
Ich habe vorhin schon gedacht, es müsste, ist es Napoli? Das wäre jetzt mein erster.
Nein, nein, nein.
Inter?
Nein.
Milan.
Nein. Milan ist auf Platz 20. Milan ist letzter in Pressing-Intensität. Ja, das ist das typische Allegri halt. Tief stehen, tiefer Block, daneben umschalten. Es ist Como von Fabregas. Fabregas Como läuft extrem hoch an. Und jetzt kommt der Fact dazu, diese drei Mannschaften, also Como, Bologna und die Roma, sind auch die drei Mannschaften mit der besten, mit den besten Abwehren, statistisch. Also Pressing kann sich auch defensiv auszahlen. Nur nur so viel dazu, kleiner kleiner kleiner Fun-Fact. Ne, Bologna wirklich herausragend, weil einige erinnern sich vielleicht noch, im vorletzten Sommer haben sie Calafiori in Zirkzee verloren. Also zwei Ausnahmespieler haben trotz des letzten Jahres diese sehr gute Saison gespielt, haben ja die Coppa Italia gewonnen und waren in der Champions League auch nach einem Stotter-Start sehr gut drin. Dieses Jahr im Sommer verlieren sie in Deuille an Nottingham und Beukäma an Napoli. Also auch wieder zwei absolute, nicht nur Stammspieler, sondern Stützen und machen trotzdem einfach weiter. Also es ist beeindruckend, was Italien aus dem Kader herausholt. Zweitbester Angriff der Liga eben auch. Also diese hohen Ballgewinne führen ganz oft zu gefährlichen Szenen. Und das vielleicht herausragendste an Bologna ist, also zumindest in Italien gibt es keine Mannschaft, also keine Trainer, der es schafft, den kompletten Kader so gut in sein System zu implementieren, dass er auch trotz vieler Wechsel den Fußball bekommt, den er sich wünscht. Beispiel. Am vorletzten Spieltag in der Serie A hat Bologna gegen Napoli 2-0 gewonnen. Napoli hat keinen Stich gemacht. Also das war wirklich, Bologna war in allen Belangen überlegen. Am Spieltag draus spielt Bologna in Udinese. Und man würde jetzt meinen, die haben Napoli hergespielt. Das hat er seine Stammelf gefunden. Italiano nimmt sechs Wechsel vor. Sechs. Und Bologna gewinnt 3-0 auswärts. Also er schafft es wirklich, den kompletten Kader komplett in seinem System zu integrieren. Deswegen sind die auch gar nicht abhängig von einzelnen Spielern. Klar, Orsolini, Bester Torschütze, Santiago Castro, der Neuner, der Argentinier liefern. Aber das ist ein so tiefer Kader. Der ist logisch nicht so tief wie Arsenal im Sinn von qualitativ. Aber er schafft es, Italiano aus dem Kader alles das rauszuholen, auch von 17, 18, 19, 20 Spielern. Und ich würde sagen, in der heutigen Zeit, mit den fünf Wechseln, mit den vielen Spielen, Bologna nicht zu vergessen, spielt ja auch Europa League, also die spielen unter der Woche ja auch, ist das schon eine Riesenqualität. Wenn du es schaffst, dann den kompletten Kader hinter dir zu vereinen und dann sozusagen auch von vielen Spielern was zu kriegen, die vielleicht am Wochenende davor nicht in der Startelf gestanden sind.
Also Leute, wenn ihr Bologna-Fan seid, nehmt euch ab Ende April nichts mehr vor. Bologna wird dann spielen gegen die Roma, gegen Neapel, gegen Atalanta, gegen Inter. Ach, Juve habe ich noch ignoriert. Also nehmt euch am Mitte April nichts vor. Das ist nämlich direkt das Spiel davor. Christian, wie groß im Prozent ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Bologna vielleicht sogar um den Titel mitspielt?
Schön, dass du es fragst. In Italien gibt es jetzt auch schon ein paar Dinge. Jetzt sind die Fragen aufgekommen, ja, können die vielleicht auch Scudetto? Also ich wäre noch ein bisschen skeptisch. Einfach, sie haben die Doppelperlastung. Klar, sie moderieren das super, aber sie müssen jetzt auch in der Europa-Liga ein paar Punkte liegen lassen. Da müssen sie jetzt erstmal auch wieder ein bisschen reinkommen. Ich glaube, für uns Scudetto ist es ein bisschen zu früh, aber dass die in die Champions League-Plätze mitspielen, auf jeden Fall. Also da muss auch Juve schauen, dass sie an denen dranbleiben, weil die eben, wie gesagt, die Intensität trotz der Doppelbelastung hochhalten, weil sie viele Varianten haben, weil sie nicht abhängig sind von jemandem. Und ja, letzter Satz, also Vicenzo Italiano ist wirklich, da können wir vielleicht auch mal ein großes Thema daraus machen, wenn wir jetzt über Jahre, die letzten Jahre hernehmen, ist für mich mittlerweile Vicenzo Italiano vielleicht der beste italienische Trainer, weil er hat Spezia vor x Jahren, ist mit denen aufgestiegen, hat es in der Liga gehalten, ist nach Florenz gewechselt, hat die Fiorentina zweimal ins Conference League Finale geführt, ins Coppa Italia Finale, kommt nach Bologna, nach Thiago Motta, wo alle dachten, oh, Thiago Motta hat hier das Wunder vollbracht. Und im Prinzip macht Italiano jetzt einfach da weiter, hat letztes Jahr die Coppa Italia gewonnen, das war der erste Titel seit über 50 Jahren, hat mit ihnen Champions League gespielt, ist jetzt wieder vorne mit dabei. Also die Konstanz, die Italiano einfach Jahr für Jahr sozusagen zeigt für dem, was er, also erreicht sozusagen immer seine Ziele mit der Mannschaft, die er gerade hat. Und deswegen ist es für mich nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis der bei einem, sag ich mal, großen Namen ankommt. Aber der Punkt ist ja, er macht ja Bologna mittlerweile auch ligamentär und schon zu einem großen Namen. Also das ist ja auch mit sein Verdienst. Letzter Satz dazu, Milan war ja vor der Saison interessiert, aber Italiano hat gesagt, nee, ich bleibe in Bologna. Mein Weg bei Bologna ist noch nicht zu Ende und das untermauert da in dieser Saison wieder beeindruckend.
Also wenn wir diese Sendung machen, dann müssen wir nämlich auch genau darüber sprechen, warum so heiß begehrte Trainer dann bei ihren Teams bleiben. Denn mit Fabregas bei Como ist es ja ganz genauso.
Genau, dasselbe Spiel. Genau, am vergangenen Wochenende war ja Milan gegen Inter, das große Derby in Mailand. Und das hätte vor der Saison, wenn es nach den Plänen von Milan und Inter gewesen wäre, wäre das nicht Kibo gegen Allegri gewesen, sondern Fabregas gegen Italiano. Weil Inter wollte ja unbedingt Fabregas eben auch. Aber Fabio Barca hat gesagt, ich bleibe bei Como. Como ist eine andere Geschichte, da haben wir schon darüber gesprochen, können wir auch gerne wieder darüber sprechen. Aber Bologna und Italiano, Italiano hat sich da auch ganz klar zu Bologna kommen, mit dem gesagt, nein, nein, wir machen da weiter. Und guter Punkt, Max, das kann man definitiv auch mal aufgreifen, um zu zeigen, wie andere Clubs nachhaltig gut arbeiten und das dann auch schaffen, große, vielleicht talentierte Trainer länger zu behalten, weil sie ein gutes Konzept ausgearbeitet haben.
Ich weiß nicht, wann Leipzig gegen Leverkusen gespielt hat oder noch spielt in dieser Saison, aber nach allem, was ich gehört habe, nach den Plänen der Verantwortlichen, wäre das Fabregas gegen Fabregas gewesen auf der Trainerbank.
Ja, die Idee hatten ein paar andere auch mit Fabregas.
Also der ist wirklich sehr hoch im Kurs. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie oft ich den gehört habe, wenn ich mal jemanden gefragt habe, wen würdet ihr denn jetzt verpflichten von Tränen für euer Team?
Ohne da jetzt irgendwie, Chris weiß da logischerweise mehr, aber falls irgendwann mal bei Arsenal die Erdthetära zu Ende gehen sollte, was wahrscheinlich noch lange dauern wird, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass bei Arsenal auch der eine oder andere Gedanke an Herrn Fabregas gerichtet werden würde.
Soweit sind sie ja gar nicht auseinander vom Alter.
Ja, ja, eben, genau. Also es ist ja gar kein Thema bei Arsenal, aber ich sage nur logisch, denn den Ruf, den sich Fabregas schon erarbeitet hat, der ist nicht das Schlechteste.
Okay, aber ich wollte gar nicht so sehr von Bologna wegführen, aber danke für diesen Sneak Peek, weil wir haben sie ja zuletzt, wenn man es mitbekommen hat, dann gegen Freiburg gesehen und da hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht, dass es so positiv gerade läuft, gut ein Update zu bekommen. Und wenn wir bei talentierten Trainern sind, die mit kleineren Mitteln Erfolg verschaffen, Jakob, dann frage ich mich, ist Alexandre Dujoe dann auch so ein heißes Träneisen? Denn der ist bei Angé der Übungsleiter, wie man so schön sagt, und bei denen läuft es nämlich auch sehr gut.
Ja, bei denen läuft es gut. Ich würde aber jetzt nicht Alexandre Dujoe auf eine Stufe mit Vincenzo Italiano stellen wollen. Ich glaube nicht, dass Dujoe in Zukunft bei einem wirklich größeren Verein zu sehen sein wird. Es ist eher eine Sache, die bei Angé auffällt, dass sie sehr große, ja, wenig Fluktuation auf der Trainerposition haben. Also Dujoe ist jetzt auch schon seit Anfang 2023 im Amt. Allgemein hatte Angé seit 2006 nur fünf verschiedene Trainer. Also, ich glaube, da muss man auch, findet man in Europa auch nicht viele Vereine, bei denen das der Fall ist. Und es fliegt aber alles ein bisschen unterm Radar. Also ich glaube auch Angé ist so, wenn man sagt, okay, wir überlegen uns mal die 18 Vereine aus der Liga, dürfte das bei den meisten so mit der letzte Verein sein, auf dem man dann kommt. Obwohl sie jetzt tatsächlich seit 2015, 16 bis auf eine einzige Saison immer in der ersten Liga gespielt haben in Frankreich und auch tatsächlich nur in der Abstiegssaison schlechter als Platz 14 gestanden haben. Also tatsächlich auch häufig so im unteren Mittelfeld gelandet sind und letztendlich stehen sie ja jetzt auch auf Platz 11 im Mittelfeld ganz gut da. Und ja, vielleicht zum Vereinshintergrund noch ein bisschen. Es ist ein netter Fakt, dass sie im Stade Raymond Coupar spielen. Also der große Raymond Coupar hat früher, hat seine ersten Profischritte bei Angers gemacht, bevor er dann zu seiner Weltkarriere aufgebrochen ist und ja unter anderem auch einen Ballon d'Or, glaube ich, gewonnen hat. Also da auch eine historische Persönlichkeit. Aber ansonsten ist Angers ein recht kleiner Verein und das ist dann auch der Grund, warum wir jetzt drüber sprechen wollen, dass es durchaus bemerkenswert ist, dass sie auf Platz 11 in der Tabelle stehen. Vor allem, weil sie vor der Saison auch von vielen als einer der heißesten Abstiegskandidaten gehandelt wurden, weil sie mit Esteban Le Paul und Bamba Diemg zwei ihrer drei besten Torschützen der letzten Saison verloren haben. Also Diemg hat fünf Tore gemacht, war aber von Lorient nur ausgeliehen, die ja letzte Saison noch zweite Liga gespielt haben, dann aber aufgestiegen sind, ist jetzt bei Lorient geblieben. Und Le Paul ist ja kurz vor Transfer-Schluss für 13 Millionen ungefähr nach Rennen gewechselt. Ich glaube, da hat David ja auch in der letzten Folge drüber gesprochen, meine ich zumindest, dass er ihn da auch erwähnt hat. Und performt daher jetzt auch ganz gut, hat letzte Saison 13 Tore geschossen von insgesamt auch nur 32 Toren. Also da ein Drittel oder sogar deutlich mehr als ein Drittel der Tore erzielt. Und da war dann die Prognose durchaus naheliegend, dass es bei Anjel wirklich nur gegen den Abstieg geht. Ich will sie jetzt auch nicht da komplett rausnehmen aus dem Abstiegskampf. Es sind auch nur fünf Punkte auf Platz 16, der ja auch in Frankreich die Relegation bedeuten würde. Und vor allem, wir hatten vorhin bei Bernie schon über die Überperformance von Miles Vila gesprochen. Und einen solchen Fall gibt es auf jeden Fall auch bei Anjel. Denn die haben im Tor Ervel Kofi, einen 29-Jährigen, den Nationaltorhüter Burkina Fasos, der von Lens ausgeliehen ist, hat eigentlich noch keine große Erfahrung in der Ligue 1. Und der spielt wirklich bisher eine überragende Saison. Der hat acht, mehr als acht Tore nach Expected Goals und Target Prevented. Also ist da maßgeblich für eine dann doch recht große Überperformance von Angers verantwortlich. Sie hätten eigentlich so 24 Tore kassieren sollen. Nach Expected Goals und Against sind jetzt bei 15, was dann im Umkehrschluss die viertbeste Abwehr der Liga ist. Da stellt sich dann natürlich aber definitiv die Frage, ob das über die Saison aufrechterhalten werden kann. Sie haben auch– Kofi hat auch schon zwei von drei Elfmetern gehalten. Also vielleicht ist das jetzt auch ein Zwischenhoch. Und diese gute Abwehr muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen, dass es sich durch die ganze Saison zieht. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall bemerkenswert. Und er spielt auch wirklich eine überragende Saison. Also in ganz vielen Spielen ist er dann der, der Angers wirklich rettet. Jetzt am Wochenende hat man 1-0 in Toulouse gewonnen. Da hat Toulouse auch noch dreimal Aluminium getroffen. Und Kofi hat auch noch ein paar Bälle richtig gut rausgeholt. Also läuft ganz gut bisher bei ihm.
Aber eben, wie gesagt, nur geliehen ist es nur ein Kofi to go. Also er wird– Entschuldigung, ich musste ihn machen. Ich habe aber trotzdem noch eine kurze Rückfrage zu Angers. Denn wenn ich mir hier angucke, wie so die Transferbilanz der letzten Jahre aussieht, da ist es wirklich auffallend, wie viele Spiele Angers hochzieht aus dem eigenen zweiten Team. Und in dieser Saison, vor dieser Saison, war es ja besonders drastisch. Man hat eben nur Kofi und Mouton, der bisher auch eine ganz okaye Rolle spielt, so nach seiner Einseitszeit, gemessen. Die hat man beide verpflichtet. Ansonsten eben Abgänge gehabt. Auch Routonji ja unter anderem zu St. Pauli. Brauche ich die ja nicht erzählen. Grüße an den Flugkopfball an der Stelle. Aber wenn ich jetzt mal einen meiner berühmten Bundesligavergleiche mache, ist Angers quasi der SC Freiburg der französischen Liga. Dass man eben vor allem aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs die Spieler hochzieht und so in der Liga bleibt?
Ich habe da auch darüber nachgedacht, ob man den Vergleich gut machen kann. Zuerst aber einmal Untonji, das ist nur sein Bruder. Das ist nicht der, der jetzt bei St. Pauli spielt. Ah, das stimmt.
Satriko Untonji, ja, da hätte ich mal besser gelesen. Ja, lustig. Ich dachte mir noch, warum ich das nicht wusste. Okay, deswegen.
Aber ansonsten ist es wirklich bemerkenswert. Also ich habe auch mal nachgezählt, es sind jetzt 11 Spieler im Kader, also die bei Transfermarkt im Kader stehen. Das ist ja immer so ein bisschen schwammig, je nachdem, die aus der eigenen Jugend stammen. Und das ist schon echt bemerkenswert, gerade wenn man halt nicht so ein großer Verein ist. Und ich glaube, wenn man jetzt an französische Talentschmieden denkt, ist auch Angers auch da nicht der erste Name, der einem einfällt. Und gerade in der Offensive ist es halt bemerkenswert. Also wir hatten ja darüber gesprochen, dass sie ihre zwei besten Stürmer eigentlich verloren haben. Der andere, der letzte Saison noch mehr Tore geschossen hat, ist Imad Abdelhi im Mittelfeld, der jetzt auch noch da ist. Der hatte sechs Tore gemacht in der letzten Saison. Jetzt in dieser Saison erst ein Tor. Und aber zwei Namen sind da durchaus zu nennen, die auch beide jetzt aus dem B-Team gekommen sind im Sommer mit Ziddiqi Scherief und Prosper Peter. Mit dem wunderschönen Namen auf jeden Fall. Die sind beide erst 18, haben jetzt beide auch jeweils schon drei Tore gemacht. Und das, obwohl sie auch schon einige Spiele mal verletzt verpasst haben. Also jetzt auch noch nicht so sonderlich viele Minuten gesammelt haben. Die aber durchaus Potenzial haben. Und das ist halt wirklich bemerkenswert, dass es dann so ein kleiner Verein da schafft, so einen Abgang zumindest bisher aufzufangen, mit zwei wirklich ja komplett unerfahrenen Spielern, die aber jetzt in der Liga 1 durchaus zeigen, dass sie auch schon mithalten können und ja mit 18 auch noch ganz schön viel Luft nach oben haben im Normalfall.
Aber wirklich und also Award für den schönsten Namen dieser Sendung geht auf jeden Fall an Prosper Peter. Das muss man sagen. Das ist ein ganz fantastischer Name. Also so ist die Situation in Orangé. Wir machen noch einen kurzen Flug über die Ligen. Fabian, was hast du uns denn aus Spanien noch mitgebracht?
Ich habe euch noch Espanyol Barcelona mitgebracht, den anderen Club aus Barcelona, auch ein spanischer Traditionsverein, der momentabellen Sechster ist. Und das ist schon bemerkenswert, denn vor zwei Jahren waren wir noch in der zweiten Liga und gehörten noch einer chinesischen Investorengruppe. In der zweiten Liga wurde der Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft hochgezogen, Manolo González, und der ist nach wie vor Trainer. Der ist sofort mit denen wieder aufgestiegen, hat im ersten Jahr die Liga gehalten und ist jetzt im Moment Sechster, und das überhaupt nicht zu Unrecht in der Primera Division. Und seit Oktober gehört der Verein übrigens nicht mehr den chinesischen Investoren, sondern er gehört zu Alan Poes und dem VeloCity Sports Partners. Dem gehört unter anderem auch Burnley, wie ich recherchiert habe. Und dann die, also wir haben hier wieder kleines Multiclub Ownership. Fantastisch. Das dachte ich doch, dass dich das interessiert, Max.
Habt ihr auch gehört, dass Uli Hoeneß jetzt wieder gesagt hat, 50 plus 1 muss abgeschafft werden, dass so Teams wie Hamburg, der HSV, der VfB und so weiter, dass die richtig geile Investoren kriegen. Man nennt es so. Ja, das wird halt dann der Viertverein für die Investoren. Das wird richtig klasse für den VfB. Viel Erfolg damit. Aber gut.
Ja, aber Espanol macht trotz alledem sehr gute Arbeit, muss ich sagen. Wie gesagt, ist eigentlich der kleine Gruppe aus Katalonien und eigentlich auch so eine Fahrstuhlmannschaft. Sind jetzt aber wie gesagt 6ter, machen das richtig gut und haben einen Trainer, der sich auch nicht scheut, die Liga zu kritisieren wegen Montagspielen, wegen irgendwas. Also normalerweise kuschen die Spanier ja sehr gerne vor der Liga und sagen nichts dagegen. Und das ist einer, der immer wieder sagt, Auslandsspiele finde ich kacke, Montagsspiele finde ich kacke, die Ansetzungen finde ich alle scheiße. Der nimmt kein Blatt vom Mund und das finde ich sehr, sehr sympathisch. Und ich muss natürlich noch einen Stürmer hervorheben. Und zwar ist das Roberto Fernandez Rhein, U21-Nationalspieler Spaniens, der vorher wo gespielt hat.
Ich komme nicht drauf, es hört sich an wie eine Eissorte.
Er kommt vom FC Malaga, er ist hier groß geworden. In der Jugend haben wir den ausgebildet. Er hat uns von der 3. in die 2. Liga wieder geschossen. Und dann ist Sporting Braak aus Portugal auf ihn aufmerksam geworden. Haben ihn uns abgekauft. Und da hat er aber nicht eingeschlagen, ist dann zu Espanyol weiter. Und dort ist er richtig gut unterwegs. Ist zwar nicht immer Stammstürmer, aber macht seine Sache trotzdem ganz gut. Ist jetzt eingewechselt worden, zum Beispiel gegen Sevilla. Hat ein wunderschönes Siegtor geschossen, das 25 Metern. Großer Hühne, blond, was für Spanier jetzt nicht ganz üblich ist, aber der auch wird seinen Weg machen. Und der wird auch, wenn er so weitermacht, bei dem einen oder anderen größeren Verein noch landen. Und dann vielleicht noch ein kleiner Hinweis zu einem englischen Spieler, eine sehr interessante Verpflichtung. Da kamen Ablöse frei von Blackburn. Hatt ich überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm. Tyrus Dolan war mal U20-Nationalspieler. England ist inzwischen 23 und spielt da bei Espanol Stamm und macht richtig Dampf auf dem Flügel. Einfach nur so dachte ich vielleicht, kann Chris da was zu sagen? Ich hatte den überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm. Ich auch nicht. Sehr gut. Und vielleicht ein letzter Hinweis. Christian Riedl ist zu Espanol Barcelona gewechselt von Darmstadt aus der zweiten Liga. Am Ende des Transfer Fensters. Innenverteidiger hat auch sechs Spiele von Anfang an gemacht und durchgespielt. Da kam er ein bisschen näher, ich glaube von 12 oder 13 Spielen. Also völlig überraschend, ist mir auch nicht bewusst gewesen. Und plötzlich sehe ich da so einen deutschen Innenverteidiger bei Espanol. Auch sehr interessant. Er hat gutes Potenzial, war auch ein O21-Nationalspieler schon mal Deutschlands. Und mal gucken, was die noch so machen. Also die haben bei Espanol ein ganz gutes Package zusammen im Moment. Und wie gesagt, sind Tabellen sechs da. Und ja, mal gucken, wie es weitergeht bei denen.
Sehr interessant. Und bei den Expected Goals against liegt Espanol 0,1 vor Barcelona. Also dem großen Barcelone. Es tut mir jetzt fast ein bisschen leid, das so formuliert zu haben. Aber ihr wisst, wie ich es gemeint habe, liebe Hörer.
An denen sie übrigens auch den Torwart verloren haben, der letztes Jahr so richtig stark war. Juan Garcia, der ja jetzt auch sich verletzt hat. Ah gut, Barcelona und Torhüter ist eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema. Also Espanol haben wir jetzt im Blick. Und natürlich auch Thierrys Adolin, der aus der U19 von Preston zu Blackburn gewechselt ist und davon dann zu Espanol. Also wirklich schockierend, Chris, dass du das nicht auf dem Schirm hast. Dabei war er doch mit 15 noch in der Jugend von City und ist dann zu Preston und dann ist er zu Clitherow und dann– ja gut, okay, ich lasse es. Gut, aber Chris, wenn du noch mit dabei bist, was hast du noch als letztes Premier League-Thema? Du wolltest noch mal über Thierrys Adolin wahrscheinlich sprechen.
Genau, das Thema nicht passt. Ja, ich habe ein kurioses Thema aus der Partie Everton gegen Manchester United und zwar war das in der 13. Minute, da hat Edrissa Gay Michael Keane eine Ohrfalge verpasst und rot gesehen. Und das Kulisse daran ist, die spielen beide in der gleichen Mannschaft. Das war so ein bisschen das Gesprächsthema jetzt die letzten Tage. Die haben sich ein bisschen in die Haare gekriegt nach einer Chance von United. Und daraufhin hat Keane Gay ein bisschen gestummt. Gay hat dann mit einer Ohrfalge reagiert, hat rot gesehen, was auch regeltechnisch konform ist. Ich glaube, das wird in Deutschland ähnlich sein. Aber wenn man eine Tätigkeit macht, ist es eigentlich ganz egal gegen wen. Gerade wenn es Richtung Kopf und Gesicht geht. Aber das Witzige fand ich, zum einen hat Elberten trotzdem gewonnen. Trotz des grünen Platzverweises wurde dadurch zur ersten Mannschaft überhaupt, die zu zehnt in Old Trafford gewinnt. Echt? Ich überhaupt? Ich glaube für mehr die Historie. Wir müssen noch mal nachschauen.
Ja gut, aber trotzdem krass.
Okay, trotzdem, genau. Ebenfalls interessant, es war der erste Sieg für Mois in Old Trafford, seitdem er bei Manchester United als Trainer kläglich gescheitert ist. Und eben Jena Mois fand ich ganz witzig, hat über die rote Karte gesagt, dass er das ziemlich mag, dass seine Spieler kämpfen. Es zeigt, dass sie nicht alles hinnehmen und akzeptieren, wenn jemand nicht 100 Prozent gibt oder etwas falsch macht. Es zeigt, dass sie tapfs sind und diese Mentalität will er vorleben. Die will er in seiner Mannschaft. Das fand ich auch ganz witzig. Aber es ist anscheinend halb so wild. Geij hat sich entschuldigt. Jena hat auch gesagt, dass es aus der Welt ist. Aber das war eine nette Anekdote vom Spieltag.
Und Everton liegt damit eben vor Liverpool in der Termine. Das ist natürlich ganz wichtig. Und Geij hatte aber wahnsinnig Glück, dass das Spiel gerade unterbrochen war. Denn wenn das Spiel noch gelaufen wäre und er gibt seinen Mitspieler im eigenen Strafraum eine Ohrfalge, dann gibt es Rot und Strafstoß. Kleiner Regelfun-Fact. Dafür hört ihr doch den Rasenfunk, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Für Multiclub Ownership schlechte Wortwitze und das. Also, Everton, ein interessantes Wochenende auf jeden Fall kann man so sagen. Bernie, was haben wir denn in der Serie A noch zu besprechen?
Ich bringe euch noch kurz Maurizio Sarri's Lazio mit. Auch ein spannendes Thema, vielleicht zur Einordnung im Sommer. Lazio, aufgrund von wirtschaftlichen Restriktionen, durfte Lazio keinen einzigen Spieler verpflichten. Also Sarri ist zu Lazio gekommen und es wurde dann erst relativ spät im Transferfenster klar, dass gar nichts gemacht werden kann.
Da hat er wahrscheinlich auch ruhig darauf reagiert, so wie wir ihn kennen.
Maurizio Sarri hat die letzten Wochen gesagt, wenn es nicht Lazio gewesen wäre, sein neben Napoli sein Herzensverein, dann wäre er gegangen. Genau, aber da es eben Lazio war, hat er gesagt, komm, jetzt stehen wir jetzt irgendwie durch. Und dementsprechend katastrophal war der Saisonstart. Die haben einiges verloren, aber jetzt eben, und deswegen habe ich sie kurz mitgebracht, in den letzten acht Spielen nur ein einziges verloren gegen Inter. Sie haben in diesen acht Spielen auch mit die meisten Punkte in der Liga geholt, sind jetzt wieder dran, sind dann Juve zum Beispiel dran in der Tabelle, sind wirklich in Sichtweise der europäischen Plätze. Und deswegen, ja, schön, dass Lazio quasi diese Energie aus sich selbst herausgeschöpft hat. Sari und die Spieler verweisen logischerweise seit Saisonbeginn darauf, gut, dann ist das jetzt halt womöglich so diese Wagenburg-Mentalität. Wir sind es, brauchen wir jetzt gar nicht lang drüber heulen, sondern es gibt keine anderen Alternativen, wir müssen es hinkriegen. Und das schaut jetzt echt deutlich besser aus, wie gesagt, sie sind in Flo gekommen, haben jetzt am Wochenende Kaljeri geschlagen, haben Ljube auch geschlagen vor einigen Wochen. Und Provedail hast du schon angesprochen, genau, haben auch eine sehr stabile Defensive. Und das Schöne, deswegen habe ich es mitgebracht, Sari hat jetzt nach diesem Kaljeri-Sieg gemeint, seine Mannschaft hat ihn heute an das Napoli von vor sieben, acht Jahren erinnert. Und das Napoli von vor sieben, acht Jahren war Saris Napoli, das wir vielleicht auch noch ein paar in Erinnerungen haben. Ich sage nur Mertens, Calahon, Insigne. Und allein, dass Sari dieses Gefühl hat, dass die Mannschaft, Lazio, auch so ein bisschen diese Vibes ausstrahlt. Er hat auch gesagt, klar, die ist technisch bei Weitem nicht so stark wie damals sein Napoli, aber halt einfach hat gemeint, wie wir das Spiel aufs Feld bringen, wie wir das Spiel lesen. Er hat Freude daran, hat er gesagt, wir haben alle Freude. Und das ist, finde ich, schön, dass die Ursprungs-Sariball-Mannschaft, nämlich das Napoli von damals, dass allein die Erinnerungen bei ihm geweckt werden, zeigt, dass Lazio auf einem guten Weg ist. Und jetzt am Wochenende fahren sie in San Siro zu Milan. Und wie gesagt, müssen sich da in keinster Weise verstecken, weil sie echt gut den Ansari-Rhythmus wieder gefunden haben. Und das, obwohl zum Beispiel mit Tati Kasseianos oder Rovella zwei ganz, ganz wichtige Spieler schon seit Wochen verletzt fehlen. Also er hat eh nichts vom Transfermarkt bekommen. Dazu fehlen ihm noch Leistungsträger verletzungsbedingt. Und trotzdem hat der Lazio wieder in die Spur gebracht. Maurizio Sarri.
Fünf der letzten sechs Spiele zu Null gespielt, Napoli. Aber du musst mir noch ganz kurz sagen, Bernie, also es gab keine Transfers. Ich sehe hier aber auf transfermarkt.de, sehe ich Transfers für diese Saison. Also Rovella, Tavares, Gigolo, Pellegrini.
Genau, das ist diese typische, das ist leider ein bisschen ein Problem auf Transfermarkt. In Italien ist es ja ganz oft so, da wird ein Spieler im Sommer verpflichtet, erst mal auf Leihbasis.
Ja, okay und dann?
Aber der Punkt ist eben der, es gibt ja noch wirklich, du kannst ja ein Spieler auf Leihbasis verpflichten und dann würde der kommenden Sommer erstmal wieder an den Ausgangsverein zurückgehen und dann muss man halt schauen, wie geht es weiter. In Italien ist aber sehr häufig, dass ein Spieler zwar erst mal auf Leihbasis verpflichtet wird, aber da die Kaufpflicht schon drin ist. Im Prinzip geht es nur darum, die Ausgabe ins nächste Budgetjahr reinzuschieben. Aber es ist in dem Moment schon klar, dass der Spieler fix bei Lazio ist. Deswegen passiert es manchmal bei Transfermarkt, dass man oft bei italienischen Vereinen denkt, die haben im Sommer noch mal vier neue geholt. Aber die haben sie eigentlich schon im Sommer davor geholt, weil das schon damals fest mit der Kaufpflicht verbunden war.
Okay, alles klar. Sehr gut. Ich dachte mir das schon, aber ich wollte eben einmal kurz nachfragen. Dann blicken wir nochmal nach Frankreich. Und da, Jakob, gehen wir ganz ans Tabellenende und blicken auf ein Team, das nur acht Punkte hat nach den ersten 13 Spielen und vor allem erst sieben Tore erzielt hat.
Genau, das ist Aji Okser. Die stehen wirklich nicht gut da bisher in dieser Saison. Und das liegt vor allem an der Offensive. Du hast die sieben Tore angesprochen. Den sieben Toren gegenüber stehen auch 15 Expected Goals. Also eine wirklich absurde Unterperformance in der Offensive. Das sind verschossene Elfmeter, das sind vergebene Riesenchancen. Das ist wirklich alles auf einmal. Man muss dazu sagen, auch Okser hat sogar alle der drei Top-Torschützen der letzten Saison verloren im Sommer. Mit Ahmed Traoré, der ausgeliehen war von Bournemouth, jetzt bei Marseille unter Vertrag steht, da aber nicht so wirklich zum Zug kommt. Gaëtan Perrin ist nach Russland gewechselt, zu Krasnodar. Und auch Jubal, einen Innenverteidiger, der aber letzte Saison auch sechs Tore gemacht hat für Okser, ist ebenfalls zu Krasnodar gewechselt. Also da zwei der drei besten Torschützen zu Krasnodar gegangen, der andere ist auch weg. Und das ist dann auch tatsächlich schon der Hauptgrund, warum es in der Offensive nicht so gut läuft, weil der andere sehr wichtige Offensivakteur bei Okser ist Lassin Sinaiyoko, der aber auch in dieser Saison massive Probleme im Abschluss hat. Das kommt bei ihm nicht so ganz überraschend. Der war im Sommer kurzzeitig auch mal bei St. Pauli im Gespräch. Da habe ich mich dann auch etwas näher noch mit ihm befasst. Und das ist auch eher so ein mitspielender Stürmer, der viele Vorlagen gibt. Und jetzt ist aber halt die ganze Last der Offensive irgendwie momentan auf seinen Schultern hat man das Gefühl. Und das bekommt er dann nicht so gut hin, auch wenn er weiterhin eigentlich ein sehr wichtiger Spieler für Okser ist. Und dann wahrscheinlich auch einer der wichtigen Faktoren wäre, wenn man da unten noch mal rauskommen will. Ansonsten ja, sieht es da momentan nicht so gut aus. Aber es kann natürlich auch immer sein, gerade wenn die Zahlen eigentlich besser sind, es ist ja auch tendenziell, sage ich mal schon mal, vielleicht ein Zeichen, dass es auch Pech dabei ist und es auch noch schnell besser werden kann. Dementsprechend ist jetzt auch Trainer Christoph Pellissier noch nicht so komplett unter Druck, zumindest meines Wissens nach. Und ja, man muss mal schauen, ob sich das jetzt in den nächsten Wochen vielleicht ein bisschen wendet. Man muss dazu sagen, es ist ja auch im Tabellenkeller sehr eng in Frankreich. Es gibt viele Clubs, die momentan Probleme haben. Also bis mit einem Sieg könnte Ux ja auch schon auf Platz 15 springen. Das wendet sich jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen relativ schnell. Und wir haben es ja auch bei Metz zum Beispiel gesehen, die ja, als wir die Folge aufgenommen hatten, gerade ihren ersten Sieg gefeiert haben, dann dreimal in Folge gewonnen haben und dann plötzlich im Mittelfeld standen. Jetzt haben sie letztes Wochenende verloren mal wieder und sind jetzt wieder auf Platz 17 abgerutscht. Und es gibt in Frankreich auf jeden Fall genug Vereine, die sich da nicht so schnell rausbewegen werden, glaube ich, aus dem Abstiegskampf. Also so sieben Teams, würde ich mal sagen. Von Platz 11 würde ich eigentlich nur Paris FC rausnehmen, bei denen ich jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarte, dass sie da unten längerfristig drin sein werden. Und dementsprechend ist jetzt auch bei Auxerre noch nicht Alarmstufe rot, auch wenn man momentan das Schlusslicht ist in der Liga.
Das ist interessant, weil so ein bisschen ist es übers Knie gebrochen, aber so leichte Parallelen zu St. Pauli, einem deiner anderen Herzens- und Vereine, kann man da schon erkennen, weil eben sehr lange in der 2. Liga gewesen, dann für ein Jahr hochgekommen, direkt wieder runter. Das ist natürlich das, wo es sich leicht unterscheidet. Aber eben letztlich eigentlich ein Zweitligateam, das jetzt in der 1. Liga angekommen ist, im 1. Jahr ohne Probleme, weitgehend ohne Probleme, den Klassenerhalt geschafft hat und jetzt aber im 2. Jahr Probleme hat und das auch noch mit der Offensive. Also man hat ja auch nach Expected-Goals-Werten nur die drittschlechteste Offensive der Liga. Also es ist jetzt quasi selbst, wenn man alles gemacht hätte. Wäre es noch nicht so arg viel besser, wir gucken mal, ob der Rasenfunk, ja es ist ja dann kein Fluch, sondern ob das Rasenfunk Glück dann zuschlägt, so wie bei Metz damals. Kaum haben wir über sie gesprochen, haben sie nur noch gewonnen. Ich musste ihr erst mal lachen, wenn ich mir die Ergebnisse angeguckt habe. Dann habe ich mir ein gutes Timing. Schauen wir mal, wie es für Oxair ist. Ja ihr 4, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das war wie immer ein wunderbarer Flug über die Ligen Europas und über total interessant, welche Verbindungen. Ich gucke mir ja vorher eure Themen an und dann denke ich mir so, ja gut, schauen wir halt einfach mal, wie es wird. Und dann gibt es immer irgendwelche Querverbindungen, die ich natürlich nicht auf dem Zettel hatte. Aber ihr. Also vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank an Chris McCarthy, an Jakob Haffke, an Christian Bernhardt und an Fabian Pakulat. Danke euch. Ja, sehr gerne.
Danke, Ebenso. Sehr schön.
Aber ich ehrlich gesagt, ich reite euch da eigentlich auch immer ganz gerne rein, mit so einer offenen Verabschiedung. Und ich danke natürlich aber auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und euch würde ich nie in irgendetwas hinein reiten, denn warum auch ihr finanziert den Rasenfunk. Ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorndfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Nico Putzel, bei Krösi, bei Maria, bei Marvin Michel und bei Thomas. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt in den vergangenen Jahren, sondern sie haben sich auch registriert auf rasenfunk.de. Da findet ihr generell auch alle Informationen dazu, wie man uns Geld zukommen lassen kann. Und ansonsten empfehle ich euch sehr, höht euch gerne die Tribüngespräche zum Investoreneinstieg bei der DFL an. Und ansonsten bleibt oder werdet gesund und uns gewogen. Bis bald im Rasenfunk. Ciao. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.